The End Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Hallo Leipzig! Hey, schön, dass Sie da sind. Hallo! Hey Leipzig, was geht's? Hier ist Stefan Tietze.
Dankeschön, er ist hier. Ich habe es einrichten können. Wir haben es geschafft. Und das hier ist Florentin Will, meine Damen und Herren. Er ist einer, er ist einer, er ist einer, Ach was.
Leipzig, schön, dass ihr da seid, freut uns.
Wie geht's euch, geht's euch gut?
Ja, herrlich, herrlich, wir haben noch nichts gemacht, beruhigt euch, alles ist okay. Aber ich finde es gut, man hat direkt gesehen, welche Art Menschen wir sind, wir haben nämlich jeweils Handtücher mitbekommen und ich habe gemerkt, du bist so ein U-Handtuchträger. Ja, ich bin der klassische, ich will meinen Körper verstecken, das ist nur, ich will möglichst viel von meinem Körper verdecken schon. Aber ich habe tatsächlich gemerkt, als ich heute dieses T-Shirt ausgesucht habe, dass es als einziges T-Shirt... Moment, ganz kurz, es gibt einen Aussuchprozess bei dir? Du hast einen T-Shirt-Aussuchprozess? Ich bin nicht... Ist das mehr so ein... Ja, es ist so ein bisschen ein T-Shirt pro Monat, so und dann habe ich so wie Bart Simpson einfach dreissig Mal dasselbe Outfit im Schrank stehen. Aber ich habe tatsächlich bemerkt, dass dieses T-Shirt wie kein anderes meine Brustwarzen betont. Und dabei habe ich gleichzeitig bemerkt, dass anscheinend nur meine linke Brustwarze steif wird. Aber du hast eine fantastische Brustwarze. Dankeschön, dankeschön. Nee, wirklich, ist mir häufig aufgefallen. Kriegt man nicht häufig? Danke. Das ist ein Applaus wert.
Danke.
Ich weiß, das Wort trifft es nicht ganz, aber das fällt mir halt ein.
Pikante, pikante Brustwarze, die sind so schön klein und toll.
Weil ich habe die nicht, sobald ich ein bisschen Körperfett zunehme, kriege ich wirklich Brüste.
Und dann döllen die sich so aus.
Ich wurde wirklich mal operiert an meinen Brüsten. Habe ich es dir mal erzählt, Herr Iber kurz? Moment mal, kommt jetzt die Brust-OP des Stephan-Titzes raus, wirklich? Ja, ich habe mir meine Brüste machen lassen. Du hattest da vorne ein klassisches D-Körbchen. Nee, ich hatte wirklich, ich habe einmal mal alles mitgenommen, damals hätte ich Trischerbrust und Brüste. Das heißt, es ist einmal alles verkehrt gewesen, oben rum. Wie wenn man auf so ein Knetmännchen einmal draufdrückt und dann kommt es woanders wieder raus. Irgendwo muss es ja hin. Da kann sich der Körper auch kommen in die Brüste, einfach scheiß drauf. Nee, und dann wurde es wegoperiert tatsächlich. Da war es einfach so, weil es sich auch dann entzünden kann oder was auch immer. Das ist auf jeden Fall so eine Krankheit und dann wurde es mir wegoperiert. Und dann bin ich so ein paar Tage mit so Auffangbehältern rumgelaufen, wie mir dann so drauf gemacht wurden, da wurde dann das Blut drin gesammelt. Was? Du hast dann ständig geblutet, oder? Und die Zahnspange, Leute, das war ein Anblick, das war ein Anblick, als ich mit den Messdienern mit diesem Outfit im Freizeitpark war. Wow, okay. Satan! Ja, genau. Aber war das, sag ich mal, ein Arzt im Sinne von medizinisch geschulter Arzt? Ich komme in Schwitzen, aber es liegt nicht an dieser Story. Nee, aber war das ein schönheitschirurgischer Eingriff? Ja, ich glaube, man würde es so bezeichnen. Ich glaube, schönheitschirurgischer Eingriff, wir werden ja nicht bezahlt von der Krankenkasse. Und der wurde bezahlt, was, glaube ich, dafür spricht, dass es auch gesunde... Ich bin schon länger her, das war sehr früh, so kurz nach der Pubertät. Und der Arzt hatte dann so eine Zehner-Stempelkarte mitgegeben, so zum nächsten Mal. Weil sie noch mal rumkommen. Die zehnte OP ist umsonst, kein Problem, sie kommen noch heute. Gibt es das eigentlich bei Ärzten auch sowas, bei Schwerenschirurgen? Ich glaube schon. Das ist doch nichts anderes als so ein Angebot, was man einfach mal ein paar Mal um... Herr Thietze, Sie haben Glück, Sie sind heute in diese Praxis gekommen, wir haben heute tatsächlich zwei OPs zum Preis von einem. Wirklich? Das heißt, zu Ihrer Knie-OP dürfen Sie sich noch eine völlig kostenlose OP mit dazu aussuchen. Was darf sein? Sie sind Doktor Schönherr. Ja, Doktor müssen Sie ... Sagen wir Herr Schönherr, Paul, sagen wir Paul. Okay, sagen wir Paul. Sie hatten bei Yamee da so viele gute Bewertungen, nämlich. Ja, ja, ja, richtig. Es ist üblich mittlerweile, dass man verschiedene Umständen hat. Genau, zwei zum Kreis von eins. Also wie gesagt, wir haben alles da, wir haben Nierendings und Fett, so. Nierendings? Ja. Fett? Ja, Fett in Niere, Niere in Fett, wie Sie es möchten, kein Problem. Was nehmen denn die meisten? Boah, das ist natürlich schwierig. In Ihrer Altersgruppe würde ich tatsächlich sagen, drittes Auge. Das ist Auge? Ja, ist momentan sehr beliebt. Und Bonus beim dritten Augen kriegen Sie ein kostenloses T-Shirt dazu. Moment, ganz kurz. Was für ein Shirt? Drei Augen sehen mehr. Aber wo kann ich das Auge hinmachen, das ist egal? Das ist tatsächlich egal, Sie können das hin machen, wo Sie wollen. Ja? Ja. Auch auf den Finger. Wo würdest du dein Auge hin machen? Auf den Finger. Ja, so wie so Schnee, gell? Ja. Da kannst du überall um die Ecke gucken und so. Kannst du ... Das ist viel cooler. Wir hatten heute das klassische Gespräch, was würdest du ... Nein, nein, nein, Leute. natürlich, what? Das ist die neue Farbe. Wir machen jetzt auch Dirty Humor. Es ist aber die klassische Antwort. Stefan Tietze wurde heute auch die Frage gestellt, welche Superkraft er hätte. Und er wählt die Superkraft, die zu 100% ausschließlich von Perversen benutzt wird, nämlich Unsichtbarkeit. Klingt erstmal cool, aber wir alle wissen, was man mit Unsichtbarkeit machen würde. Einfach der auch nicht in der Justice League aufgenommen, der unsichtbare Typ mit einer Riesenerektion. Und er sagt, noch bist du nicht unsichtbar, mein Lieber. Die Hose, die Jeans kann man gut sehen. Wir sehen alles. Ja, es gibt vor allem viele Parameter, die man halt beachten muss. Also was ist alles unsichtbar? Muss man zum Beispiel ganz nackt sein? Also wenn ich jetzt einen Anorak anziehe, sieht man den dann? Ist es dann ein floating Anorak oder was? Wie lange bin ich unsichtbar, ist es anstrengend unsichtbar sein, ist es wie Luft anhalten, einfach so ein... Und dann kannst du dich unsichtbar bewegen oder sowas. Aber glaubst du, es macht wirklich einen Unterschied, ob jetzt in einer Frauendusche einfach nur nichts ist oder ein schwebender Anorak oder was? Wie würde man da, wie würde man denn darauf reagieren und dann gesagt... Ja, gut, aber Anorak, wir wissen es nicht, die Frauen unter euch, habt ihr schon mal einen schwebenden Anorak in der Umkleide gesehen, ist doch üblich vielleicht. Ja, oder so eine Duschhaube einfach und so ein Shampoo, wenn ich schon mal hier bin einfach, ist das Shampoo? Und du meintest dann auch so, ja, das ist die eine Sache, die man entweder sagt, um zu spannen oder um einen Tresor auszurauben.
Ja, klar.
Ja, aber wie willst du, da habe ich mich gefragt, wie dumm, unsichtbar ist.
Nicht denken.
Ja, aber wie willst du denn einen Tresor ausrauben, wenn du unsichtbar bist? Du lässt dich einsperren, während die den aufmachen. Ja, aber okay, alles klar, gut. Erst mal stirbst du dann, weil keine Luft da drin ist. Nein, nein, nein. Aber okay, vielleicht braucht man auch keine Luft, wenn man unsichtbar ist, das weiss ich auch nicht. Du gehst mit deinem Kumpel zur Bank, ja, und dann sagst du dem, heb mal fünf Euro ab. So, dann sagt der Kumpel, dann sagt der Kumpel, guten Tag, Herr Bankmanager, und währenddessen gehe ich ein, ja, aber was dann, ja, dann bin ich im Tresor, da bist du jetzt in dem Tresor, wo lauter Fünfer rumliegen, da bist du jetzt dann drin, so, und dann am nächsten Morgen geht die grosse Tresortür, wird wieder von zehn Gringotts-Kobolden aufgemacht. Dann wird die aufgemacht. Und dann, glaubst du, wundern die sich nicht, dass da ein Floating-Anorak drinsteht, der mit so Goldnuggets auf dem Arm, dass Goldnuggets rumfliegen. Die sind doch geschult! Ich glaube nicht, dass sie geschult sind, ehrlich gesagt. Die sind doch geschult für solche Fälle. Ich glaube nicht. Seminartag eins, die drei besten Donut-Überzüge, Seminartag zwei. Ja, falls, also nur damit Sie es wissen, falls Sie mal den Tresor aufmachen und dann fliegt ein Geldschein neben den, einfach mal mit dem Schlagstock so drei Zentimeter über den Schein schlagen. Ich glaube nicht, dass Sie darauf vorbereitet werden, ehrlich gesagt. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Was hast du genommen nochmal? Fliegen? Was war deine Kreativität für Superantwort? Meine Superkraft war, ich darf so viel essen, wie ich will, ohne Fett zu werden. Das war meine Superkraft. Auch da Justice League-Antrag pending, würde ich mal sagen, wurde noch nicht angenommen. Aber es ist die beste Superkraft, definitiv. Es ist eine gute Superkraft. Wird alles besser. Du bist glücklich ja auch. Du wirst ja auch
glücklicher aus, wenn du was isst, was dir schmeckt. Und was schmeckt ist ja auch Fett, primär Fett. Hauptsächlich Fett. Hast du schon mal reine Butter, reines Fett gegessen? Ja, es gab schon mal schwache Momente, da ich einfach gedacht, fuck it, Jalousien runter und dann wird die Butter aufgemacht. Ich habe tatsächlich als Kind mit meinem Cousin immer in dem Haus meiner Oma mit meinem Cousin Cousin.
Boah, da gibt es ja immer mehr mit dem Wort Cousin, oder? Ja, ich habe es. Das ist immer so ein bisschen suspekt. Ich finde Leute, die dann Cousin, dann will ich, das ist auch, dann irgendwann reicht es auch. Cousin. Ich habe ja noch diese Französisch-Air-App auf dem Handy und die fährt natürlich schon ein Ampeu ab, sage ich mal. Ja, ich habe kein Wort verstanden. Deswegen ist Cousin. Und wir haben im Haus meiner Oma nach Süßigkeiten gesucht, haben keine Süßigkeiten gefunden, haben aber Zuckerstückchen gefunden. Man findet im Haus von Grosseltern keine, oder was Surat gesagt hat, man findet keine Süßigkeiten. Also After Eight ist das Beste, was man rausholen kann. Ja. Viel alte Kaugummis, abgelaufene Kaugummis, aber in Grosseltern gab es das nie. Dann sind sie gestorben. Tatsächlich hat meine Oma dann mal im Altenheim... Da gab es dann wiederum was Süßes auf der Beerdigung. Ja, also pro, contra, Leben, Tod, wer weiß. Weiss nicht, ambivalentes Verhältnis. Da habe ich meine Oma im Altenheim besucht und dann war an jeder Ecke After-Aid und ich dachte mir einfach nur so, ich kann nicht darauf warten, alt zu werden. Wie so Spender, wie diese Disinfektionsspender, die an dieser Tür hängen. Einfach, Leute, ich brauche was. Da kann sie so ziehen. So ein Hebel, du musstest mit dem Kinn so an den Hebel. Einfach direkt, die können ja nicht kauen. Einfach so reingeschoben. Die können ja nicht kauen, deswegen wird es denen direkt in den Magen geschossen. Flüssig. Oh, das wäre geil, so Infusionen. So flüssiges After-Aid einfach. Ja, ja, ja. Kannst du das einstecken und dann auch... Herrlich, herrlich.
Und tatsächlich muss man sagen, es ist ja wahnsinnig heiß, muss man sagen, und es beginnt die Eiszeit.
Und ich habe vor einigen Jahren mal so einen kompletten Ben & Jerry's Humpen und dann hieß es dann so, ja, ein bisschen aufwärmen lassen, damit der so smooth ist.
Und dann habe ich ihn ein bisschen zu lange aufwärmen lassen und dann war der halt komplett flüssig.
Und ich bin nicht stolz, das zuzugeben, aber ich glaube, ich habe den fast geäxt, glaube ich, einfach mit so dieses Ding, also 2700 Kalorien und ich einfach so, das waren schöne 0,7 Sekunden meines Lebens. Ja, das stimmt, das hält dann aber auch nicht vor, oder? Also du bist dann nicht für drei Tage hast du keinen Hunger mehr, sondern du kannst dann am nächsten Tag auch schon wieder essen. Ja, ich weiß es nicht, aber ich glaube, das ist so das Beste, was andere haben dann irgendwie so Schnaps im Flachmann und nicht einfach so geschmolzen ist bei den Jerrys. Manchmal hängen die Teigdinger so ein bisschen in der Öffnung, aber es funktioniert gut. Finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig heiß geworden, oder? Unangenehm heiß gerade. Es ist unglaublich. Wer ist denn hier so heiß, hallo? Wer macht's hier denn so warm? Da reibt jemand die Hände, hallo? Heiße Gäste? Du bist doch völlig wahnsinnig. Reibt die dir Hände oder was? Das sind die beiden, die wir vorher im Baumarkt getroffen haben. Wir waren gerade noch kurz im Tom. Ja, wir haben sie so einen schönen Ofen gekauft. Ich fand es sehr praktisch. Ich liebe Baumärkte, ja. Dieser Geruch und warum riechen alle Baumärkte gleich? Das verstehe ich auch bis heute nicht. Es ist eine Mischung aus Holz und Arbeit. Na, ich glaube, es ist einfach, ich glaube, dass je mehr Gerüche du mischt, irgendwann riecht es immer gleich. Also es gibt so einen Punkt, ab dem, wenn du neuen Geruch hinzufügst, verändert es den Geruch nicht mehr. Das ist wie Parfümerin. Riechen auch alle gleich. Diese Lernphase, fucking Duolingo. Riechen alle gleich, einfach, obwohl die einzelnen Parfums unterschiedlich riechen. Das ist genauso wie beim Baumarkt, wo dann einfach so verschiedene Holzsorten, Ahorn, Hickory, kommt alles zusammen. Aber ich habe immer noch grossen... Baumarkt ist so ein Laden, also Supermarkt habe ich durchgespielt, muss ich jetzt auch ganz ehrlich sagen. Riechen aber auch nicht alle gleich. Ich finde, Lidl hat einen starken Eingeruch, Rewe hat einen starken Eingeruch und Edeka und Rewe riechen gleich. Aus irgendeinem Grund, Lidl und Edeka, das war deutlich anders, es riecht ein bisschen mehr nach Plastik im Lidl irgendwie. Stimmt schon, aber dieser Geruch löst in mir nichts mehr aus. Ich habe das Gefühl, Supermärkte habe ich irgendwie durchgespielt. Ich bin jetzt schon 17 Jahre lang auf dieser Erde und habe einfach schon alles erlebt, was man in Supermärkten erleben kann. Wohingegen beim Baumarkt, ich würde mich nie im Leben trauen, da irgendwie mir so Holz zuschneiden zu lassen oder so, würde ich mich einfach nicht nicht trauen, da habe ich einfach jetzt noch eine Herausforderung vor mir, wo ich einfach weiß, den habe ich noch nicht freigeschaltet. Da gehe ich hin und dann sammle ich jedes Mal ein bisschen Erfahrungspunkte. Ich würde gerne mal in einem Baumarkt übernachten. Oh ja. Einfach mal. Oh ja, schön in so einem Planschbecken. Weil die sind ja riesig. Ja, dann trägst du diese Teiche, die man sich kaufen kann, diese Fertigteiche, trägst du einfach um und dann war das immer, was passiert. Ich habe tatsächlich immer als Kind Planschbecken ausgeleert, umgedreht und reingekrochen. Ja, und dann kamen dann die ganzen Kumpels mit Badehose und Bier und sagten, what the fuck, das ist die Poolparty. Das war der schönste achtzehnte Geburtstag meines Lebens, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Wir wollten hier feiern. Ja, ich fand das toll, weil dann ist es schattig und du musst dich nicht bewegen. Du kannst dich nicht bewegen. Ja, wir wollen uns bewegen und Sonne. Das ist diese Party, das Gegenteil, von dem es in deiner Einladung stand. Es gibt ja auch viele alte Leute, wo wir jetzt beim Thema Tod noch mal sind, viele alte Leute, die suchen sich schon zu Lebzeiten ihren Sarg aus. Und ich finde, das ist eine geniale Idee. Ja, finde ich auch super. Weil jetzt mal wirklich nicht doof gedacht, ein Sarg ist ein ultranützliches Möbelstück. Ultranützlich, klingt jemand an der Tür, schön ein Sarg. Es ist zu heiß, du gehst in den Sarg, schön iPad rein, du bist da drin, es ist perfekt. Und ich glaube, du hast weniger Angst vorm Tod, wenn du jetzt schon schöne Stunden im Sarg verbringst. These, These, vielleicht neue Weltreligionen, mal sehen, mal schauen. Ich weiß nicht genau, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, weil mir hat es geholfen, wenn Familienmitglieder, oder wird es richtig intim heute, aber wenn Familienmitglieder sterben, hilft es doch, dieses ganze Prozedere, das Sargbesorgen etc., dass man Arbeit hat, du musst Dinge, du musst dich beschäftigen, dich mit etwas und so und du wirst abgelenkt, das ist doch total sinnvoll. Deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob ich den Familienmitgliedern das abnehmen will, mir den Sarg ausruhen, aber die werden sich natürlich den hässlichsten Sarg. Ich würde mir niemals den Sarg ausruhen, die sich meine Familienmitglieder, was sie mir zu Weihnachten schenken. Du willst ja den roten Ferrari-Sarg, haben wir uns geeinigt. Mit Lenkrad immer noch?
Ja, bitteschön.
Du musst sowas immer updaten, weil wenn du mit acht
sagst, ich hätte gerne einen Ferrari-Sag
und du datest es nie ab, dann denkt man
ja, jetzt ist er tot, schade.
Und jetzt, was gilt denn? Du musst es immer
updaten. Einfach so, übrigens
Update, ich möchte jetzt keinen Ferrari-Sag.
Ja, so damit alle wissen,
Ahorn, alles klar, ja, Ahorn, alle Hörner, die ihr finden können, alles rein. Macht einfach, was ihr wollt. Oh, what the fuck, da oben stehen ganz viele Menschen noch. Oh fuck. Ist das eine Razzia da oben? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Hey, Leute. Über uns ist noch eine zweite Bühne, wo irgendwie noch ein zweiter Podcast... Ja, ich wollte auch jetzt sagen, wie so eine Parallelveranstaltung. Den die anschauen. Das wäre eigentlich mal so, du kennst ja wahrscheinlich Battle of the Bands, wo dann die spielen und dann wer ist am ehesten noch erträglich und der kriegt Applaus. Besser wäre es doch, wenn die Gegenüber spielen würden und dann... Wer lauter ist, gewinnt. Lauter und wo sich die Leute hindrehen. So und dann am Ende guckst du einfach, wer hat sich in welche Richtung gedreht, weil es gibt einfach Leute, die können wahnsinnig laut klatschen, die klatschen lauter als drei andere Leute, das ist unfair, wohingegen wenn du dich einfach drehst, in die Richtung ist es fair.
Das Applausometer ist unfair?
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Ja, natürlich ist es unfair.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass du jetzt nicht die beste Band der Welt hattest, Stefan, aber das Applausometer ist einfach demokratisch gesehen.
Wer hat mal Bandcontest mit dem Applausometer gewonnen?
Ich weiß. Ich bin Fan vom Applausometer ist einfach demokratisch gesehen. Wer hat mal Bandcontest mit dem Applausometer gewonnen? Ich weiß. Ich bin Fan vom Applausometer. Glaubst du, wenn wir unsere Wahlen komplett durch Applausometer ersetzen würden? Ja, aber ist es nicht in der Schweiz oder in so einem einen Ort? Das stimmt. Da gibt es doch Applausometer noch. Ich glaube, ein Ort, wo es ausgewürfelt wird und ein, wo einfach ein großes Applausometerli und dann alle kommen am Marktplatz zusammen. Wo war das jetzt, wo die Regierung ganz lange weg war? Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, Belgien oder Italien oder irgendwie sowas. Da fand ich es auch total interessant, dass die Politiker gesagt haben, ja, das Schlimmste, also die hatten keine Regierung mehr für ein paar Wochen, und die haben gesagt, das Schlimmste, was jetzt passieren kann, ist, dass die Bürger merken, dass man eigentlich gar keine Regierung braucht, also dass es auch ohne geht, und die so denken, Moment, wir brauchen keine Regierung, wir müssen nicht wieder wählen, wir müssen nicht diese ganzen Plakate anschauen, cool, wir lassen es einfach. Aber finde ich auch gut, dass der Politiker das so gesagt hat, so das Schlimmste, was jetzt passieren kann, ist, dass die Leute merken, dass sie uns nicht mehr brauchen. Das Schlimmste, was ihr gerade merken könnt, ist, dass wir die ganze Zeit nichts getan haben. Es wäre nicht so clever, das zu sagen. Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, wel welches Land das war. Wahrscheinlich ist es so wichtig.
So gehe ich an Nachrichten ran. Aber das ist auch nicht gut, dass dann auffällt, dass Belgien nicht so wichtig ist. Naja, ich sag mal, wenn ich es mir nicht merken kann, wird es auch nicht so wichtig
gewesen sein. Das ist meine Herangehensweise. Das ist ein Credo. Einfach so, brauchst du nicht. Aber jetzt
apropos, tatsächlich Breaking News, vor kurzem oder vorgestern oder so, haben so Aktivisten den Bundestag gestürmt, habe ich jetzt gerade gesehen, die haben sich dann alle auf den Boden gelegt und so. Und er hat gesagt, dass er die Stimme der Stimme der Stimme der Stimme der Storsitzenden hat, der hat dann mega weird einfach in der Situation so eine riesige Glocke rausgeholt und hat mit dieser Glocke geläutet. Und ich sage, man sah ihm genau an, dass der schon seit Jahren darauf wartet, mit dieser Glocke zu läuten. Der kommt ja am ersten Tag angerollt, er sich hin und sagt so, Bundestagspräsident, alles klar, okay, ihr hört mich jetzt. Was ist das? Was ist denn das eigentlich? Die Glocke, für Notfälle. Ja, Herr Schäuble, das ist die Glocke. Und also, was? was? Kann ich die immer? Naja, also wirklich nur in Ausnahmefällen, Herr Schäuble. Ja, aber wenn jetzt, weiß nicht, jemand einschläft oder so. Nein, also wirklich nur, wenn es gar nicht mehr anders geht, nur dann die Glocke, okay? Also in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik wurde sie, glaube ich, auch nur zweimal geläutet und dann aus Zufall. Okay, weil zufällig jemand mit seinem Bein dagegen gekommen ist. Okay, also bitte... Das kann bei mir nicht passieren. Deswegen haben wir Sie gewählt. Alles klar. Viel Glück, toi, toi, toi, Herr Schäuble, Sie machen das schon. Danke, ciao. Ich bleib immer noch da das erste Mal, okay? Die ersten Sitzungen sind immer betreut, so ein bisschen dann... Ja, heute. Betreut des Bundesratspräsidenten. Alles klar. Aber das ist wirklich fantastisch. Und dann gab es diesen Vorfall, also dann muss man sich vorstellen, kam so fiemenartig so ein Überfall von Leuten, die dann gegen das Klima, scheiss Klima gerufen haben. Und dann hat er die Glocke geläutet. Was passiert dann? Das weiß niemand. Alle dachten so, man beschwört Hitler nochmal oder sowas, wenn man die Glocke läutet. Wäre das, wenn so ein Drache kommt und dann diese Glaskuppel zersprengt,
wenn die Drache dann diese Leute weg springt. Oder man holt noch mal die Rote Armee, so Break in case of Hitler oder so, dass man dann einmal und dann einfach, es geht noch mal los. Da kamen Sicherheitskräfte oder was? Da kamen Sicherheitskräfte und das Tolle war, die haben sich auf den Boden gelegt als irgendwie stille Protest und einer hatte so ein Transparent und dann kamen so zwei Sicherheitsleute, die haben das genial gemacht, weil die sind dann reingerannt und haben einfach nur dieses Transparent weggezogen und sind dann einfach gegangen. Und dann standen die alle da mit ihrem stillen Protest und alle so, wogegen, wofür und die so, ja. Niemand hört euch mehr. Und das ist eigentlich genial, so dann kann jeder sich in diesem Protest aussuchen, was er haben kann. Immer ein Shirt gehabt? Nee, kein Shirt. Keine Shirt. Der allergrösste Fehler zu Protesten, immer ein Shirt mitnehmen. Oder ein Zweitbanner. Nee, kein Zweitbanner. Und dann standen die da und dann ist so, ja, schwierig. Dann lassen wir es. Kein Plan B, immer einen Plan B haben. Zur Not einfach nochmal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, fragen, können wir auf dem großen Projekt der Mario Kart spielen. Oder irgendwas einfach als Plan B, wenn man es dann macht. Aber ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Und in der Überschrift stand Klimaaktivisten, ich glaube, das war aber einfach nur geraten, einfach oder so. Wir haben das Banner auch nicht gesehen. Wogegen werden die denn wohl protestieren? Das ist schon spannend. Gegens Klima? Ich weiß es nicht. Aber ich glaube, damit kann man so eine Regierung am meisten verunsichern, wenn man einfach sagt, wir protestieren, wir sagen aber nicht wogegen. Weil das ist so umgekehrte Psychologie, dann sagt die Regierung, oh scheiße, sie wissen es.
Irgendwas ist im Busch.
Fuck, sie wissen es, fuck, Bigfoot, nein.
Dachten, das ist ein Kostüm.
Was glaubst du, was von diesem Bullshit, die Bild braucht man wieder Programm im Sommer, Sommerlochthemen, was davon stimmt?
Bigfoot oder doch der Pterodactyl, der über die Türkei gesehen wurde, was ist es?
Es gibt ja immer wieder so ein Problem, Bern.
Es kann nicht alles hoax sein, da muss was von stimmen.
Es ist ein, was ist es?
Es gibt ja immer wieder so ein Problembär. Das kann nicht alles hoax sein, da muss was von stimmen.
Es gibt ja immer den Problembär, es gibt immer den ganz grossen Fisch, einfach so ein dicker Fisch gefangen.
Genau, so ein Superhai, Megalodon.
Ja, da hatte ich tatsächlich, als ich im Koisselehr gearbeitet habe, mein Vorgesetzter war ein grosser Fischfreund, der kam rein und hat mich mit den Worten begrüsst, hallo, ich bin der Claudius und ich mag Fische, im Aquarium und auf dem Teller. Ich bin einfach so, okay, hi. Ich hätte sofort gekündigt. Aber ich finde es so gut, wenn man Leute einfach so in einem Satz zusammenfassen kann. Ich bin Leute, die sich selber in einem Satz zusammenfassen können. Ja, man braucht manchmal so eine Woche, bis man jemanden so eingeordnet hat, so fuck, vielleicht wählt der rechts, keine Ahnung, oder so, aber bei dem war es einfach so... Okay, Leipzig funktioniert das nicht, okay. Aber da war es einfach so ganz klar, ich mag Fische, ich schaue sie gerne an, aber ich esse sie auch gerne. Und der hat dann immer die Zeitung gelesen und hat dann immer so mir das Bild gezeigt, ah hier, grosser Fisch gefangen, so gross ist der doch nicht. Und ich schaue mir diesen Fisch an und denke mir, nee, oder kleiner, winziger Fisch.
Aber hat der so klischee-mäßig auch so Angelerfolg-Photos in seinem Büro hängen?
Gar nicht. Das war tatsächlich eine merkwürdige Gestalt, weil manchmal musste man dann auch
seinen Vorgesetzten anrufen, wenn irgendjemand anruft und tatsächlich dann sein Geld zurück
will und dann ein grosser Alarm. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, wenn du bei mir zu Hause anrufst, dann musst du ein bisschen häufiger klingeln lassen. Weil meistens bin ich im Keller, bei den Fischen. Was machen die im Keller? Und ich habe mir immer vorgestellt, dass der einfach in irgendeinem Zeitpunkt seines Lebens beschlossen hat, den gesamten Keller zu fluten, einfach bis zur Decke und komplett mit Fischen zu füllen. Und dann zieht er immer seine Badehose an oder nackt einfach, je nachdem und wartet da so runter und schwimmt mit den Fischen und immer so, ist das die, das die, ne, okay, alles klar, ist das Telefon, ne, alles klar und Fisch dann, oh, ne, okay, und so, ist der Wahnsinn, der bestimmt so ein Riesenhai auch bei sich unten im Keller, das kann sein, egal oder dann, bis zu welcher Größe sind Fische legal, gibt es da eigentlich irgendwie so ein, so ein Rochen oder so, sieben so ein Rochen? Ein Rochen? Ja. Ich glaube schon, dass es ein Rochen kaufen oder so. Ich weiß nicht, wo du den dann kaufst. Ich wurde fast von dem Stachelrochen umgebracht. Ja? Ja, fast. Du hast ein Bild von dem Rochen gesehen. Es waren so sechs, sieben Meter war ich von dem Drochen entfernt.
Aber das ist auch echt, man kommt nicht so, ich war schnorcheln.
Und dann, ich bin auch kein guter Schwimmer.
Und ich bin halt froh, einfach da rumzupaddeln und so.
Aber meistens, wenn da eine Strömung kommt, dann habe ich auch schon die Kontrolle verloren so ein bisschen.
Und dann bin ich halt, dann habe ich mich erschrocken. Also die ganze Zeit, dieser ganze Kurs, der Vorbereitungskurs war schon so seltsam,
weil du, der Bestandteil zu zehn Sekunden, ja, atmet durch diesen Strohalm und hat die Brille auf und die anderen zwei Stunden dieses Vortrags waren und das sind alles Fische, vor denen ihr Angst haben solltet. Dieser Fisch bläht sich auf, ist saugiftig, tötet euch, das ist ein Stachelrochen, tötet euch. Das sind Haie, bleib lieber weg.
Das sind meine Kinder, sorry, ich weiß nicht, wie die angekommen sind, alles klar.
Ja genau, das war einfach sehr gefährlich und ein Fisch, der Drückerfisch, der stößt dich an, also der will dann die Eier bewachen oder was auch immer, Fische, wie Fische gebären und ich glaube aber tatsächlich, also Eier und dann kommt der mit so Riesenlippen, so ein bisschen so Dori-artig und dann kommt der auf dich zu mit so sehr viel Anlauf und rammt dich. Und da hatte ich wahnsinnige Angst. Der ist nicht giftig oder der kann dich auch nicht töten, aber ich hatte einfach Angst, von einem Fisch gerammt zu werden. Das ist einfach diese Vorstellung, ich habe so Angst gemacht und deswegen hatte ich die ganze Zeit Panik und hatte so ganz gross aufgerissene Augen und diese Brille hat es nicht besser gemacht auch und bin dann da rumgepaddelt und habe dann halt vor diesem Drückerfisch Angst gehabt. Im Grunde will er dich ja küssen eigentlich, wenn er so grosse Lippen hat und dich dann so wegdotzt. Nein, nein heißt nein, Fisch. Vielleicht hattest du Angst, dich zu verlieben, wer weiß. Ja, vielleicht. Das ist ja schwierig, so eine Fernbeziehung. Und dann habe ich gesehen, dass da die ganze Zeit ein Stachelrochen direkt unter mir war, während ich panisch mich umschaugehalten habe nach diesem Drückerfisch, war die ganze Zeit unter mir so ein Stachelrochen, der gesagt hat, Alter, Alter, komm nicht näher, Dude, Dude, und er hat so diesen Stachel so angelegt, aber ich glaube, da passiert dann auch erstmal nichts. Aber Steve Irving ist doch so gestorben, oder, dieser Crazy Crocodile Hunter? Aber wurde der nicht direkt ins Herz gestochen oder so, wurde der nicht irgendwie direkt irgendwie direkt, also ging es da gar nicht darum, dass es... Der Rochen war auch so, sorry, fuck, direkt ins Herz, oh shit, sorry. Kommt nach Hause, Schatz, du glaubst nicht, was heute passiert ist. Das war, und die Frau, setz dich erst mal, setz dich erst mal, was ist passiert, setz dich erst mal. Wir schauen ein bisschen Fernsehen. Was ist passiert? Was ist passiert? Ja, da kam so ein Typ angeschwommen und ich dachte mir, ja klar, kein Problem, Stachelrochen steht im Namen, jetzt muss ich auch mal stacheln. Hast du gestachelt? Ich habe gestachelt, ich dachte mir einfach so, komm, der war nah und er guckte mich so an und ich dachte, was will der von mir und dann habe ich ihn einfach schön weggestachelt. Dann kommt der Sohn und will die neueste Folge von diesem Steve Urban schauen und dann der Vater A. Ich muss kurz weg, ich muss kurz weg. Schade, glaubst du, der wurde von seinen Rochenfreunden so exkommuniziert, ausgeschmissen? Ja, ich glaube, Rochenknast. Ja, einfach so rausgerochend. Rochen ist auch ein rocher Name. Es klingt so, als wäre der irgendwie danach benannt, wie irgendjemand, wie das Geräusch klang, als jemand das erste Mal ein Rochen gesehen hat. Einfach so, Rochen, Rochen. Ja, Rochen, da ist viel Abneigung drin, auch Rochen. Ja, Rochen. Das ist deine Geste für Rochen. Das ist deine Bewegung, keine weg. Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich auch in Zeichensprache einfach die Geste für Rochen. Ich habe gelernt, dass Zeichensprache ist extrem rassistisch, die haben irgendwie immer die krassen Klischees und Vorurteile auch für Länder irgendwie, Deutscher ist so, also Bier trinken einfach und sowas in der Richtung. Ja, ja, so dieser Bart. Ja, hatten die diesen Bart oder haben die das nur tut den ich am und dran gepappt, weil die noch Gold über hatten, wahnsinnig viel Gold auch da. Interessant, oder? haben wir den schon eingemauert, wie sah der noch mal aus? Mach den Bart mal ein bisschen länger. Dann haben die so einen Karikaturtypen. Wir haben nur, wir schlagen mal die Gazetten auf jetzt hier, die alten. Mach den Bart mal ein bisschen länger. War der wirklich so lang? Wir haben nur so eine alte Karikatur von ihnen, da haben wir ihm so ein spitzes Kinn gemalt. Ich weiss nicht mehr, wie der ist. Aber seit tausend Jahren bauen wir diese Pyramide, jetzt haben wir vergessen, wie der aussieht. Seit tausend Jahren? Bauen wir das schon dran? Hm? Nee, weil der Herr Bolz ist ein Sagjahr. Wie lange redet der schon? Fünf, fünf, zwei, sechs. Haben wir das römische System oder... Nee, wir haben das andere. Nee, wir haben Adler, Rochen, Stehender Mann. Wir haben Papyrus, Papyrus, Anubis. Nein, Adler, Rochen, stehender Mann, Jahre alt. Das weiß ich aber auch. Mach den Bart noch mal ein bisschen länger. Ich glaube, der war länger. Bis zu den Füssen. Irgendwo sind wir falsch abgebogen bei dieser Statue. Wir sind komplett falsch abgebogen. Ich finde, wir reden zu wenig über Ägypten. Ägypter waren viel, viel länger crazy am Start als die Römer zum Beispiel. Aber über die Römer reden wir andauernd. Aquädukte, wow, so. Aber Ägypter, die haben eine kreisige Gesellschaftsform gehabt, die haben ewig überlebt. Römer haben im Vergleich, glaube ich, gar nicht lange überlebt. Ist irgendwer, der hier Geschichte oder so studiert? Stimmt das? Die schämen sich. Ich glaube wirklich. Ich habe eine letzte Dokumentation gesehen über Abu Simbel, das ist einer der wichtigsten Tempel oder so, und die haben den gebaut und dann dachten die, ja, pass auf, scheisse Idee, wir bauen ja ein riesiges steinernes Gebäude, da ist es ja dunkel drin. Was machen wir denn? Und dann haben die gesagt, ja, auch gut, aber lass mich mal kurz weiterreden, wir machen ganz grosse Spiegel und holen uns dann Sonnenstrahlen von außen, tragen die Spiegel ganz schnell in den Raum und leuchten dann in den Raum rein. Wir haben tatsächlich Spiegel aufgestellt, die dann durch die Eingangstür durchgeleuchtet haben, und dann hatte einer wie so ein Scheinwerfer, konnte den Spiegel so anleuchten, auch manchmal so in die Augen geleuchtet oder so, ist der von der Leiter runtergefallen, scheiss drauf ins Klavier und hat immer so weitergeleuchtet. Oh Jeff, hör auf, ich sehe nichts, ich trage diesen Zehn-Tonnen-Stein, hör auf! Oh, ich bin auf mein Bart getreten, Idioten. Voll Idioten. Aber das dachte ich mir, das ist eine geniale Idee, einfach so mit Spiegeln, aber ich weiß nicht, wie die Single kriegt, umgt haben, Spiegel zu bauen, ehrlich gesagt. Woraus haben die Spiegel gemacht? Sand eingeschmiert. Die haben Bronze genommen und das ganz glatt poliert oder so. Na, geht auch. Geht auch. So geht's auch. Es war dann eigentlich wie so eine grosse Disco-Kugel, dass sie dann einfach so durch die ganzen Reflexionen haben, die dann überall diese Punkte hingeleuchtet. Das war genial. Ja, oder einfach ein Loch in die Decke. Gut, je nachdem. Weil so oft regnet es auch nicht da. Je nachdem, je nachdem. Aber die waren ja extrem abhängig vom Nil, ne? Wenn der Nil ja immer hochkam, dann war alles voller Wasser und dann ging der wieder runter und die haben ja nur am Nil gewohnt. Die haben nur am Nil gewohnt. Aber haben die nicht auch Krieg geführt gegen jemanden, können die nicht einfach so den Nil abschneiden oder so? Einfach sagen, so dass wir ganz viele Biber rekrutieren oder so, die einem da einfach ganz viel Holz und Damm bauen oder so. Vielleicht sind so die Ägypter untergegangen, das kann natürlich sein. Wahrscheinlich, das kann schon sein. Der Biber, ich glaube, wahrscheinlich auch die einzige, die das keine Gottheit war und die Biber dachten sich, Leute, ihr habt einen Schlagengott, ihr habt einen Katzengott, ihr habt diesen Fuchsgott, hallo, Bibergott, nichts, gar nichts. Meine größte Angst ist es, zu sterben und festzustellen, die Ägypter hatten Recht, weil ich weiß darüber gar nichts. Und ich habe auch Angst vor diesem Menschen mit diesem Panther-Masken oder sowas. Ja, ja, und dann so Heil-Raa, sage ich jetzt mal. Können Sie ein Namensschild tragen? Ich habe mich letztens daran erinnert, dass ich irgendwie als Kind immer im Bett lag. Das ist die einzige Erinnerung, die ich gehabt habe. Wenn ich nicht gerade unter dem Planschbecken lag, lag ich im Bett. Ich hatte irgendwie das Bedürfnis, Kontakt aufzunehmen zu einer höheren Macht, aber fand Gott irgendwie so ein bisschen uncool, beim Rallyeunterricht super uncool und so. Und dann da habe ich mich für den Mond entschieden und ich habe mir eine Zeit lang jede Nacht dem Mond gute Nacht gesagt, weil ich dachte, der Mond ist okay. Also weil ich dachte mir, weil ich habe da tatsächlich schon über das Argument nachgedacht, so warum sollen gerade die Christen recht haben, warum haben nicht irgendwie dann die Moslems recht oder irgendeine andere Religion recht, weil die sind Gott. Aber ich denke mir, der Mond, der wird ja nie falsch sein, weil der ist ja da. Der ist ja da, ja, du musst ja nicht mal an ihn glauben. Die würden ja nicht sagen, dass er nach dem Tod so, wie es der Mond war, kompletter Bullshit. Oh nein, alles komplett falsch gelebt, mein Leben. Aber vielleicht bist du deswegen so erfolgreich in deinem Leben. Vielleicht tatsächlich ist die Mondreligion das einzige, was tatsächlich steht. Ja. Meine Gebete an den Mond wurden alle... Ich stelle dir mal vor, überall so fragt man Prominente, wie habt ihr es geschafft, erfolgreich zu sein, und irgendwann kommt so raus, der einzige gemeinsame Nenner ist, alle haben mal so eine Kindheitsphase gehabt, wo sie zum Mond gebeten haben. Das stimmt, ja. Jede Nacht schreibe ich einen kleinen Zettel mit meinem Wunsch raus auf einen Dartpfeil und werfe ihn so hart ich kann in Richtung Mond. Und das mache ich seit 20 Jahren jede Nacht. Immer geschieht das. Jede Nacht. Genau wie ich mir dachte, ich habe manchmal wieder Fernsehen geguckt, was selten vorkommt, und da gibt es ja wirklich bei jeder Sendung Gewinnspiele, also wirklich bei jeder Sendung. Sagen wir mal Formel 1 am Wochenende. Jedes Wochenende wird da fast jedes Wochenende ein Auto verlost. Dann bei Schlag den Raab damals, bei jedem Samstagabend wurde ein Auto verlost. Bei jedem, wieder ja, weiss ich nicht, RTL-Kacke wird ein Auto verlost. Wer hat diese ganzen Autos? Also jede Woche werden bestimmt, weiß ich nicht, wie viele, sagen wir mal in 120 Sendungen Autos verlost. Statistisch gesehen müsste ich jemanden kennen, der schon mal was gewonnen hat. Ich glaube langsam, dass nur einer diese ganzen Sachen gewinnt. Ich glaube auch, der einfach extrem viel Glück hat und einfach auch Sachen gewinnt, wo er nicht dabei ist. Es muss ja eine Dimension geben, also statistisch gesehen muss es ja eine Dimension geben, wo sämtliche Gewinnspiele von einer einzigen Person gewonnen werden, immer. Vielleicht leben wir in dieser Dimension. Weil statistisch gesehen gibt es ja unendlich viele Crazy-Dimensionen, also müssten wir auch in einer Crazy-D Dimension leben wieder. Aber kennt irgendwer von euch, wer schon mal ein Auto irgendwo gewonnen hat? Eine Person, zwei. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Toll für dich! Super. Wow, du wusstest, was kann man gewinnen, eine Million oder eine Melone? Was hast du dann gewonnen? Richtig beantwortet. Was hast du gewonnen?
Peugeot, ohlala! Peugeot, Peugeot, Peugeot, Peudiere! Aber das ist doch auch doof.
Très bon!
Weil meistens kann man dann so ein richtig schönes Auto gewinnen.
Schatz, wir haben gewonnen, wirklich Peugeot.
Was denn auch? Alter!
Peugeot 200 BCC.
Müssen wir wohl den Porsche wegwerfen, keine Ahnung, um wieder Platz zu machen. Das wäre so lustig. Tod treten. Du hast auch gezeigt, was hast du gewonnen? Was hat der gewonnen? BMW da auch. Bö, aber sowas meine ich, das ist doch schön, das ist doch schick. Alles klar, wunderbar, schön BMW. Aber ist das nicht erstmal nervig, wenn du so ein Auto hast und dann weißt du nicht wohin und dann musst du eine Garage bauen und dann brauchst du ein Dach. Wie beleuchtet man die Garage von innen, dann holst du die Bronzeschalen und dann musst du wieder... Aber das sind doch auch scheißegal. Ich glaube, also die kommen an mit so einem... Woher kommt denn das Auto an? Wer fährt das Auto denn zu dir hin? Da fährt eine so Ding Dong, hallo Herr Tietze, hier ist ihr Auto. Können Sie mich kurz nach Hause bringen? Ich war aus Hamburg, ich bin fünf Stunden hergefahren.
Also ich wollte jetzt eigentlich mein Auto hier direkt haben.
Nee, ach, den mache ich jetzt ein Auto.
Dann bringen Sie mich noch kurz nach Hause.
Okay, aber keine Musik, okay?
Dann kann ich Ihr altes Auto haben.
Okay, können wir diesen einen Podcast hören, den ich gerne mag?
Ja.
Den mag ich auch sehr gerne.
Den liebe ich sogar. Und dann fahren Sie in Horge in den Sonnenuntergang. Muss eine alte Folge sein. Aber es ist so ein bisschen so, wenn du ein neues Auto gewinnst, muss das alte weg. So ein bisschen wie wenn du als Kind merkst, wenn mein Haustier stirbt, krieg ich ein neues. Und du überlegst dir, wie sehr mag ich Schnuppel. Wer sagt sie ihm? Ich sag sie, gut. Und du sitzt vor deinem Hasen und denkst dir, pass auf, jetzt neun. Das tut jetzt eine Sekunde weh, aber danach haben wir einen Labrador, okay? Wir sehen uns im Himmel, wir sehen uns im Mondhimmel. Mama! Und dann kommt der ägyptische Gott mit dem Hasenkopf auf ihn zu und du sagst, nein! Den machen wir fertig. Die Hasen hatten Recht von Anfang an. Die Hasen hatten die ganze Zeit Recht. Hasen, ey. Aber würdest du das machen, so dieses Klassische, wenn die Katze von einem Kind stirbt, kauft die gleiche Katze nochmal oder so? Ja. Jetzt ist ja Grumpy Cat gestorben, wo ich dachte, die Eltern, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, wo kriegen wir nochmal so eine Katze her? Kannst du nicht machen, stand überall in der Zeitung. Die ist doch gar nicht so alt geworden, die war ja schwer behindert, dieses Chromosom-Ding. Ja, deswegen sah die so aus, das ist wirklich kein Witz. Deswegen sah die so aus, ja. Die war nicht traurig, die war richtig glücklich. Die war richtig glücklich. Und dann so, was ist los mit dir? Kann halt nicht, guck halt, schau mal so. Das war schon wahnsinnig lustig, ne Grumpy Cat? Ja, war eine gute Zeit damals, als das Internet noch so zahm war, dass man über eine Katze gelacht hat. Das war so lustig, die haben sie auch am Eiffelturm hingestellt und sie war angebissen. Ich glaube, der ist richtig reich geworden, also die Eltern oder so was. Grumpy Cat nicht, Grumpy Cat wurde ausgenutzt total. Grumpy Cat hat nichts, eigentlich eine tragische Geschichte. Voll tragisch, ja. So diese Beziehung zwischen den Herrchen und Frauchen und der Katze und dann steht nur noch das Geld. Das ist auch wie so Eltern von Kinderdarstellern gefühlt irgendwie, die ihr Kind vor die Kamera schleppen, die so behindert, traurig guckenden Kinder. Aber auf der anderen Seite viele erfolgreiche Schauspieler, irgendwie Natalie Portman oder so, sind heute erfolgreiche gefeierte Schauspielerinnen und die haben auch als Kinder angefangen, wo du denkst, soll man dann die Eltern da, also man kann immer so die Eltern von den Unerfolgreichen, die die Nazien... Es wäre so gut, wenn sie beim ersten Oscar einfach die Eltern auf die Bühne holen. Ja, genau. Schön, dass ihr ihr Kind gezwungen habt. Ja, danke, alles klar. Natalie Portman, what the fuck?
Die war auf Harvard, ne?
Ja?
Die ist schon perfekt, oder?
Die ist super.
Wollen wir uns unbedingt in das Natalie Portman-UFO und einfach darauf hoffen, dass sie irgendwann mal zu Gast ist?
Natalie Portcast.
Perfekt. Natalie Portcast, perfekt.
Wollen wir einfach einen Podcast starten, der so lange läuft, bis wir es geschafft haben, eine Department zu Gast zu haben? Oder sie stirbt. Okay, okay, okay. Diese Frage müssen wir uns spätestens stellen, wenn sie stirbt. Dann haben wir ein Riesenproblem. Dann können sie nicht mehr Gast sein. Sonderfolge, vierstündige Sonderfolge. Nur vier Stunden? Wir machen das 80 Jahre lang. Ja. Na gut. Das ist schwierig. So lange schwierig, gebe ich auch nicht mehr. Ja. Also auch keine 80 Jahre alt. Wie alt, wie glaubst du, wirst du? Ich glaube, über 100. Ich glaube, wir werden alle über 100. Alle in diesem Raum werden über 100. Gut, statistisch gesehen stirbt er zu. An Autounfall. Fun Fact, statistisch gesehen stirbt einer von euch noch in den nächsten 24 Stunden. Fun Fact. Was für Statistik, Fun Fact. Und ich glaube, derjen weiss, dass er gemeint ist, oder, Robert? Nee, keine Ahnung, aber kann schon sein vielleicht, oder, mit genug Leuten? Kann schon sein, ja, kann schon sein. Keine Ahnung, also in so einem Beyonce-Stadion oder so kannst du auch anfangen, all the single ladies, zwei sterben von euch noch im Laufe dieses Konzerts. Grossartig. Grossartig. Ich habe mir diesen Film angesehen von Beyonce, wo sie, also, gut, nichts gegen Beyonce, ich weiß viele Fans und so, aber als ich gehört habe, Beyonce hat einen Film gedreht, dachte ich mir, ah ok, krass, sie ist jetzt Regisseurin und so und macht einen interessanten Film und so, noch andere Talente, und dann schaue ich mir den Film an und sie hat halt ihr Konzert abgefilmt. Wo ich mir auch dachte, wo ich erstmal ein bisschen enttäuscht war, als der neue Film von Beyoncé,
sie hat einfach eine Kamera bei ihrem Konzert aufgestellt.
Richtig? Ich dachte, das ist ja echt ein Bep.
Und das war einfach nur die Aufzeichnung von ihm,
und dann so ein bisschen, wie die geprobt haben oder so.
Aber war ein bisschen enttäuscht. Ich bin dran geblieben und dachte mir so,
jetzt geht der Plot langsam los irgendwie so.
Jetzt muss sie mit den gestohlenen Diamanten weglaufen oder so.
Was ist mit den Single Ladies?
Lernen die noch niemanden kennen oder was?
Was passiert da? Wo ist der Plot?
Irgendwann ... Put your hands up.
Abspann.
Und dann aber, du bist dran geblieben, bis zum Ende.
Komplett bist du dran geblieben.
Du hast das ganze Konzert auch noch geschaut.
Ja, ja.
Hast du dabei mal mitgesungen oder warst du einfach auf deiner Couch und hast das Konzert geguckt?
Ja, ich habe halt mitgesungen.
Oh, the single ladies.
Zweieinhalb Stunden lang.
Ich habe ein großes Problem mit Lyrics die ganze Zeit.
Riesenproblem.
Aber tatsächlich, im Publikum kann... Ich habe halt mitgesungen so, oh, the single ladies, zweieinhalb Stunden lang.
Ich habe ein großes Problem mit Lyrics die ganze Zeit. Riesenproblem, aber tatsächlich im Publikum kannten alle den Text, aber einer ist mir aufgefallen im Publikum, man sieht dann immer so diese Shots und alle sind so begeistert und einer sah richtig wütend aus und der hat sich gemeldet. So wirklich wie so, Entschuldigung, Frau Knowles. Sie haben da eine falsche Zeile gesungen. Entschuldigung, eine Anmerkung.
Ich dachte mir wirklich, eigentlich eine gute Idee,
falls sie dann sagt, okay, ja, einmal ganz kurz, sorry, ganz kurz mal, Piano,
ja, ganz kurz erster Stelle.
Was wollte er sagen? Ich wusste auch nicht, was da los ist, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber ich bin, ich glaube tatsächlich, ich wäre auf Konzerten auch ein bisschen zu pedantisch,
deswegen gehe ich nicht auf Konzerte.
Und zwar ich weiß nicht, ob es euch aufgefallen ist,
und jedes Mal, wenn wir eine Live-Show machen, ärgert mich das,
weil ihr habt es vielleicht mitbekommen, wir hatten die Podcast-UFO-Playlist als Einlaufmusik. Und da gibt es diesen einen Song, wo es heisst, Time keeps on slipping into the future. Time keeps on slipping, slipping, slipping into the future. Und jedes Mal will ich sagen, Ent entschuldigung time keeps on slipping into the past die zeit slipped into the past nicht into the future wenn du dich durch die wenn du dich durch die zeit bewegst dann geht die time von der zukunft durch die die Gegenwart in die Vergangenheit. Das stimmt doch. Und jedes Mal will ich sagen, Entschuldigung, ganz kurz, ich habe eine kurze Anmerkung, kann ich kurz auf die Bühne kommen, das ist falsch. Aber ich war echt jedes Mal. Kritik ist angekommen, wir würden jetzt echt gern weiterspielen, okay? Ja, nee, aber ich möchte einfach ganz kurz Time Keeps on Slipping into the Future, oder? Naja, ist da niemand auf meiner Seite. Es kommt noch an, von wo man guckt. Meine Partei hat drei Stimmen bekommen, verdammt noch mal, für diesen Ersucht. Time Keeps on Slipping into the Past. Into the Past, danke schön, war das so schwer, weiterhin viel Spaß. Keep on Slipping, Slipping. Wollte ich noch mal sagen, irgendwas wollte ich sagen. Aber unsere Playlist kommt nicht so gut an, wie ich dachte. Ich dachte, sie würde mehr... Vielleicht war diese Playlist der größte Fehler unseres Tourlebens. Heute ist ja tatsächlich die letzte Show, die letzte Show der Tour. Ja, stimmt schon. Leipzig. Traurig. Wir haben's, okay, freut, ihr freut euch, dass es die letzte Show ist? Okay. Ne, tatsächlich haben wir uns Leipzig bis ganz zum Ende aufgehoben. Ist nicht ganz korrekt, aber wir wollten einfach nach der Leipzig-Kanzel nicht so einfach wegsnacken in der Mitte. Das muss das Highlight am Ende sein, das verdienen wir einfach. Mir ist eingefallen, Stichwort Musik, aktuelle Musik. Ich muss jedes Mal lachen, und ich weiß nicht, ob ich der Einzige bin, aber bei dem Bosse-Lied, Augen zu Musik an. Da geht der Refrain hier, Augen zu Musik an, Musik, Musik, Musik. Ist das dein Ernst? Das sind die Lyrics, die dir eingefallen sind? Musik, Musik, Musik. Es klingt so ein bisschen, als ob er das in der Band vorstellt. Ich habe diese Demo geschrieben und dann kommt dann der Mütter halt irgendwie, ich dachte mir, diese Melodie wäre Musik, Musik, Musik, so halt. Und dann die fand's so geil, dass sie einfach... und er hört es dann irgendwann im Radio und wollte noch einen Songtext schreiben oder hat ihn schon geschrieben. Und die haben einfach seine Demo veröffentlicht, wo er so einen Fake-Text einsingt. Musik, Musik, Gesang, Gesang, Musik, Gesang, Gesang, Refrain, Refrain, Strophe, Strophe, Strophe, Strophe. Ich muss jedes Mal lachen, weil ich denke, die Beatles werden mal irgendwann wiederbelebt und machen das Radio an und dann singt da jemand Musik, Musik, Musik. Musik, Musik, Ende, Ende, aus. Genial, einfach, genial. Habe das auch mal jemanden gehört und der hat so ein Lied gesungen und der hat in den Text verpackt, wer den Song geschrieben hat. Der dann so und die Lyrics von Robert Keutzer und irgendwie einfach so mit die Credits. Was? Also dieses Konzept der Credits eines Films mit in den Song ein und dann einfach am Ende, so wie irgendwie kennt man bei Rapmusik, wo man dann einfach hey Pitbull, Fifty Cent, was geht ab? Hey, das bin ich, mein Name, mein Name, mein Name, mein Name, was geht ab, featuring dein Name, dein Name und am Ende und der hat halt so einen Abspann. Mein Name ist Stefan, das Fund steht für Spaß. Wir wissen es mittlerweile. Ich wollte nur sagen, das ist die gleiche Idee, das ist die Credit-Idee, die Opening Credit-Idee.
Das sollte ursprünglich unser Intro werden. Mein Name ist Stefan, das fand es schön für Spaß.
So, dann werden Sie willkommen zum Podcast.
Nene, ne, ne, ne, ich hätte es geschlossen. Wir wissen noch nicht weiter.
Intro, intro, intro, intro, intro.
Reim, Reim, Reim, Reim, Musik, Musik, Musik.
Ja, ja, ja.
Kreuz, Reim, A, B, B, A.
Ich glaube, man kommt durch ein mittelmäßiges Festival durch, indem man einfach nur solche Lieder singt.
Lass uns mal so ein, lass uns das mal machen.
Lass mal eine Platte aufnehmen. Ja. Wollen wir eine Platte aufnehmen? Ja, wir haben mittlerweile schon... Kann man das sagen, aber es gab mal im Neomagazin damals die Idee, dass wir eine Band erfinden und es zumindest mal den Musikantenstadel schaffen. Aber diese ganzen... Gibt es diese Sachen noch? Gibt es gar nicht mehr. Die Band... So malmusik oder so. Ne, was heißt, wir haben... Wie lustig wäre das, wenn wir uns als zwei Rollstuhlfahrer erzählen, die Musik machen und dann in der Live-Show plötzlich zum Refrain aufstehen. Das wäre doch wahr, die Lust... Was sollen wir machen, eine Live-Rechnung? Aber wir sind die beiden lustigen Ulknudeln mit der Ukulele im Rollstuhl. Das ist eigentlich eine geile Idee. Und wir singen wie so einen Schlagersong oder so. Und dann stehen wir zum großen Refrain, das den Halbton noch höher geht, zum letzten Refrain. Und dann stehen wir auf und dann, weiss ich nicht, woher Silbereisen. Und davor so total auf die Tränendrüse gedrückt, irgendwie so Geschichte im Musikartenstaat. Dem fehlen beide Beine. Was machen die dann? Machen die dann Werbung oder sagen die dann, oh ein Wunder
ist gestorben. Oh ein Wunder,
glaube ich. Ja, stimmt schon, das ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Jetzt können wir es aber nicht mehr machen.
Es ist ja so ein bisschen wie diese Band, was heißt Band,
wie diese Sängerin, die
ein siamesischer Zwilling ist,
aber nur eine ist Sängerin
und ihre Schwester steht
halt nur daneben.
Und sie ist halt so eine Country-Sängerin in so Country-Montur und dann Over the road! Ich hab einen Master in Economics, ich kann aufpassen. Und sie steht halt so daneben irgendwie, performt auch nicht, tanzt nicht mit. Aber nicht mal Background-Artist. Nee, wartet einfach, wartet bis ihre Schwester den Auftritt zu erinnern. Wie nervig. Aber auch da einfach dann so mitten im Song dann einfach gehen sie so auseinander und beide tanzen einfach so. Da sind alle so wow, widerlich. Und dann meldet sich einer im Publikum. Entschuldigung. Wie kann das sein? Slips into the past. Aber ich meine, du hast es gesagt, wir haben eine Band gegründet. Wir haben ein Cover-Art und einen Namen gehabt. Das war eigentlich alles. Sehr gutes Cover tatsächlich, wir beide und Max Bierhals und die Band hiess Hinter dem blauen Baum. Ich dachte immer das Album hiess Hinter dem blauen Baum. Achso, das kann auch sein. Ich weiss es nicht mehr. Also entweder, er oft heisst das Album ja genauso wie die Band. Share, Share, Song, Share. Hier ist Share von Share. Mit dem grösten Hit Share, viel Spaß, Share. Share it. Yellow.
Yellow? Das war Coldplay, ne, mit Yellow. Ja. Wo der auch nur Yellow sagt, glaube ich, auch die ganze Zeit. Dann sagt er gar nichts. Yellow und dann Music, Music, Music, Colors, Blue. Hier die grosse Pointe. Aber interessant, ist eine gute Idee, ich hätte tatsächlich mal Lust, ein Album aufzunehmen. Obwohl ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass jetzt, wo so die ganzen Schallplatten digitalisiert werden, also jetzt 2018 hat das angefangen, falls ihr euch fragt, auf Schallplatten gab es ja oft so einen geheimen Track irgendwie so hinten drauf oder so, wenn man dann irgendwie so dann auf die Nadel drückt oder so, oder dann so einen geheimen Code oder rückwärts abspielen lässt. Und jetzt, wenn die halt auf Spotify kommt, ist halt Hidden Track einfach so.
Einer der Letzte ist ein Hidden Track, Secret Track.
Dann denkst du dir, wirklich?
Bist du so Secret?
Secret?
Ich seh dich.
Man kann bei Spotify dann nichts machen einfach so.
Dann hast du einfach den Secret Track am Boden.
Aber das finde ich eine geile Idee.
Ein bisschen langweilig.
Wenn man ein Album ganz durchhört, dass man dann auf den Hidden Track kommt.
Ja.
Weißt du, wenn man manchmal ein Album durchhört, kommt ja am Ende dann irgendwas.
Spotify will ja nicht, dass du aufhörst, Musik zu hören.
Dann kommt der irgendwas danach, was so ähnlich ist.
Aber wie cool wäre das, wenn dann du den Hidden Track freischalten musst,
indem du das ganze Album hörst.
Vielleicht ist das ja auch so, und wir wissen es noch nicht.
Vielleicht gibt es ja lauter Hidden Tracks in Spotify,
und die Entwickler so, hm, hm, hm, hm.
Die eine, die war ganz knapp damals, 94, aber seitdem niemand.
Wir haben die zu gut versteckt, ich habe es dir gesagt.
Ja, zu gut, aber vielleicht eine gute Idee war, es ist einfach schade.
Und ich habe jetzt tatsächlich auch, ich habe letztens erzählt davon, dass ich in meiner Kindheit, und da kam ich auch drauf, weil ich habe dich so gesehen mit dem Handtuch, so drüber, so wie Stefan von Erkan und Stefan, der hatte auch mal ein Handtuch. Die machen jetzt ein großes Comeback, Erkan und Stefan, und ich habe deswegen aufgerufen, mir die CD zuschicken zu lassen, die haben nämlich eine Radiosendung gehabt, und da haben die so einzelne Sketche gemacht, und diese Sketche auf CD habe ich als Kind zum Einschlafen gehört. Habe ich immer so Erkan und Stefan Comedy gehört zum Einschlafen. Ah, das erklärt einiges. Und das war auch so genial, weil da hatte ich dann immer die A-Seite, und ich bin so nach der Hälfte der A-Seite eingeschlafen, und dann lief die A-Seite zu Ende, während ich geschlafen habe, Und dann beim nächsten Mal habe ich sie umgedritten und habe wieder die Hälfte der B-Seite und ich bin so nach der Hälfte der A-Seite eingeschlafen und dann lief die A-Seite zu Ende, während ich geschlafen habe und dann beim nächsten Mal habe ich sie umgedritten und habe wieder die Hälfte der B-Seite gehört, bis ich eingeschlafen bin. Das heißt, ich habe von beiden Seiten immer die zweite Hälfte nie gehört, nie. Also ich habe jede Nacht diese Kassette gehört, aber die Hälfte habe ich nie gehört, weil ich immer eingeschlafen bin. Und irgendwie, ich habe mir jede Nacht gedacht, okay, diesmal bleibst du wach, willst hören, was kommt nachdem. Wie gehst du mit dem Döner-Tier weiter? Die können doch nicht mit diesem einen Gag haben. Wie viele homophobe Gags haben die noch parat? Und dann denkst du dir einfach, okay, und dann schläfst du jedes Mal ein. Ich bin vor Aufregung eingeschlafen. Es hat nicht funktioniert. Und jetzt endlich, 20 Jahre später, habe ich jetzt die CD tatsächlich zugeschickt bekommen von einem Zuhörer. Wie lustig wäre es, wenn du die anhörst dann und feststellst, dass du diese Gags andauernd machst, weil die unterbewusst immer noch, weil die liefen, wenn du schon geschlafen hast. Oder so mein gesamtes Leben wurde schon so vorhergesagt in diesen Tracks. Und so Frank Elstner Master, also die ersten Wörter des Sketches aneinandergereiht, ergeben, du wirst die Frank Elstner Masterclass besuchen, wenn man vier Minus abschliessend Minus abschliessen. Mit einer vier Minus abschliessen, wie du gerade durchkommst, aber naja. Aber das ist eine geniale erste gute Kurzgeschichte. Ja. Ja? Ist okay. Willst du nicht mal pitchen für Black Mirror oder so? Black Mirror kommt heute in der neue Staffel raus. Nee, kam gestern schon raus. Kam vielleicht auch gestern schon raus. Ah, vorgestern schon raus. Kommt darauf an, wann ihr es hört. Kommt ein bisschen drauf an. Wär schon gehört. Ja. Aber kannst du da jetzt nicht, du hast jetzt so ein bisschen Connections zu Netflix, kannst du da nicht pitchen oder so so ein bisschen? Ja, kann man machen. Kurzgeschichte. So eine Black-Mirror-Folge? Oh, das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Eine Black-Mirror-Folge würde ich gerne immer schreiben. Ja, mach doch mal, mach doch hier die Kassettennummer. Ja. Und dann kann ich mich als Kind spielen. Das ist halt ein bisschen merkwürdig, aber das kriegen wir schon hin. Mit den Hobbits ist das halt auch geklappt, die haben die halt im Computer kleiner gemacht und so. Und jetzt gibt es auch diese App, wo man aussieht wie ein Baby und so, dann spiele ich das. Ich spiele ja die Rolle meines Lebens. Ja, machen wir. Das kriege ich hin. Ich würde gerne für Black Mirror schreiben. Ja. Black Mirror ist cool, einfach so ein cooles Format, weil man sich einfach mal eine lustige Zukunftsidee ausdenken muss. Was ist so was? Jeder hat Black-Mirror-Ideen rumliegen. Ja, klar, natürlich, aber ich will es jetzt nicht spoilern, weil ich weiß genau, zwei haben schon ihren Notizblock rausgezogen. Er schreibt nur Dollarzeichen auf seinen Notizblock, weil schon ganz genau hier Cash, Cash, bei Google so, wie viel Geld passt auf mein Konto maximal, schnell, wie viel Geld kann ich verdienen? Ja, klar. Eine schaffte Frage. Gibt es ein Maximum? Ich habe mir natürlich ein Fahrrad gekauft und dann, ich habe es geschafft, ich habe dann auch das eine Rad mit Gangschaltung gefunden in Köln und dann hat der Typ mir aber nicht gesagt, dass ich das mit dem Messern fertig gemacht habe, ich musste das dann abholen. abholen und das Geld hat er mir nicht gesagt, dass er nur Barzahlungen annimmt und ich hatte nicht so viel Geld dabei, also bin ich dann, musste ich dann mit dem Rat, durfte ich, ich musste meinen Personalausweis abgeben und bin dann mit dem Rat ganz schnell noch zur Sparkasse fahren und musste dann da am Schalter mir das Geld auszahlen lassen. Und das war der nervösste Moment meines Lebens, weil draußen stand mein Fahrrad noch ohne Schloss, weil es gehört ja noch gar nicht mehr, ich hatte kein Schloss, dann habe ich das draußen hingestellt und bin dann super nervös, mit der Karte zittern zugegangen. Und habe die ganze Zeit da gestanden, ja, ich hätte gerne so und so viel Geld und habe die ganze Zeit umgeguckt, wo das Fahrrad noch da ist. Und ich wette, die hatte schon die Hand unten am Auslösen. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Die Hand an der Knarre und ich dachte, was ist mit ihm denn los? Also dein Fluchtfahrzeug ist so ein Fahrrad einfach. Ja, genau. Dann so, ja, okay, cool, ich habe Place Beyond the Pines gesehen, ich weiß, wie das läuft, kein Ding. Und ich wäre wirklich, ich habe mir schon überlegt, wenn es jetzt jemanden nimmt, ich wäre hinterhergelaufen. Auf jeden Fall. Dem Fahrrad? Ja. Dem Fahrrad? Ich wäre ihm hinterhergelaufen. Dann hätte ich den so umgetreten. Was sollen wir denn machen? Hättest du so die Bremse gedrückt an der Seite oder so die Klingel geklingelt? Dann habe ich das Fahrrad einen Tag gehabt und dann wurde ich direkt von der Polizei angehalten. Nein! Zu schnell? Zu langsam? Also, es kam einiges hinzu. Ich war zu schnell, hatte Kopfhörer im Ohr, hatte keine Klingel, kein Licht, keine Reflektoren, und habe eine Frau entführt. Keinen Helm auf, Frau entführt und bin auf der falschen Strassenseite gefahren. Und dann kamen die Polizisten mir entgegen und haben gesagt, Alter, ja, komm ran. Such dir was aus, was willst du? Okay, und dann lustigerweise, ich habe dann sofort die Kopfhörer rausgenommen, weil ich dachte, das ist bestimmt das teuerste. Ne, das teuerste ist, auf der falschen Strassenseite zu fahren. Ah. 20 Euro. Aber wie kann man denn auf der falschen, also hat man das nicht in Fleisch und Blut, dass man auf der richtigen Seite fährt? Ja, ich dachte halt, ich musste halt links abbiegen und ich wollte jetzt nicht den grossen Weg. Und dann bin ich halt kurz mal auf die andere Strassenseite und dann war das halt auch ein Radweg. Aber ich dachte mir, das ist doch, der war auch ein breiter Radweg. Und dann kam die mir da entgegen und haben gesagt, du hast alles falsch gemacht. Aber dann, ja, 20 Euro. Mittlerweile ist es auch echt, die wollen auch keinen Ausweis mehr sehen, die zücken direkt immer dieses Kassierergerät. Und dann geht man in die Karte, man fühlt sich echt so ein bisschen seltsam. Ja, könnte jeder machen. Ja, genau, kommen einfach so Typen, da steht Polizei, falsch geschrieben, stand das noch drauf. Und dann geht man in die Karte und dann ziehen die das dann durch und dann kann sie wieder fahren. Das ist schon seltsam, man kauft sich so frei, das ist ganz seltsam. Aber gibt man da Trinkgeld?
Also im Ernst, ich würde es nicht wissen, ist es dann so... Also ich meine, es grenzt an...
Machen Sie 22.
Nochmal plus 10 wegen Bestechung, alles klar, kein Problem, mach 30.
Herr Tietze, und was Sie da im Podcast immer erzählen?
Machen Sie 32.
Na okay, alles klar, Gott. Man gibt die Geldkarte und so ein zwei-Euro-Stück ein. Aber das war so, weil ich die Taktik bei Polizisten, weil ich die Erfahrung gemacht habe, wenn man versucht, sich daraus zu reden, du verlierst. Also bin ich immer so wahnsinnig unterwürfig und sage, ja, sorry, war mein Fehler, ich weiß, da sind noch keine Reflektoren dran, habe ich mir schon bei Amazon bestellt, kann ich Ihnen zeigen, habe ich natürlich nicht, weil die dann, keine Internet, und dann habe ich mich halt versucht, rauszureden und die, nebenbei hat immer noch gesagt, ja, ist doch kein strassentauliches Fahrrad, hat immer noch versucht, mir einen draufzugehen, weil sie halt mir sagen wollte, was alles gerade falsch ist und ich wollte halt aber auch immer nett sein, das war halt, und irgendwann war sie so sehr, sie wusste nicht mehr wohin mit ihrer Erziehungswut, hat irgendwann gesagt, ja, dann fahren sie jetzt weiter. Und war halt so angepisst schon. Ich glaube, es hat sich wütender gemacht, dass ich nett reagiert habe. Mobbing durch Nettigkeit, fand ich ganz gut. Aber ich glaube, diese Polizisten sind ja jetzt auch nicht die Taffsten von der Polizeigruppe, oder? Also ich meine jetzt so die, die, die, die, die Fahrradfahrer aus von der Seite ziehen. Die waren auch auf dem Fahrrad. Die waren auch auf dem Fahrrad. Auch auf dem Fahrrad, ja. Wer kann Wheelie? Wer kann Wheelie? Okay, ihr macht Fahrradkurier. Aber wie lustig, ich dachte auch, haben die Blaulicht am Fahrrad eigentlich? So ein kleines Dürr. Müssen Sie jetzt für den Dynamo umlegen. Den schnappen wir uns, Rita! Ring, ring, ring, ring!
Haha, dann so eine Spielkarte zwischen die Speichen. Den holen wir uns. Trampelt schneller! Den holen wir uns. Das muss natürlich auch jemand machen, aber wenn ich Polizist werden würde und dann muss ich die ganze Fahrradfahrer rausziehen, dann nehme ich mir auch. Ja gut, ich habe Columbo gesehen, meine ganze Jugend lang und jetzt muss ich das machen. Aber tatsächlich, ich habe immer eine Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer im Auto an. Was? Was? Was? Ich sag mal so. Und wenn dann hier... Was? Und Auto-Radio besteht auch auf der Ausgabe. Ja, klar, natürlich. Auto aus, Motor aus die ganze Zeit. Das darfst du nicht machen, das finde ich gefährlich. Ja, ja, und dann irgendwie schon, wenn ich da die Kopf sehe, dann hier schön mal abziehen. Ja, kein Problem. Aber lustigerweise haben die... Unterm Radar. Aber Kopfhörer hatte ich auch drin, aber das hat die gar nicht interessiert. Das war denen egal. Ist das erlaubt im Straßenverkehr? Nein, ich glaube nicht. Aber darf man nicht auch eine sehr dunkle Brille nicht tragen? Wo man fast nicht mehr durchschauen kann. Was? Da gab es noch irgendeinen Fall. Da haben die jemanden aus dem Verkehr gezogen und dann haben die gesagt, ja, sie können ja fast nichts sehen mit der Brille. Dann haben die gesagt, ja, ihr könnt doch Brille tragen, wie ich will. Und die war irgendwie so 90 Prozent Lichter die hier. Absolut, ich weiss nicht mehr, vielleicht habe ich es geträumt, vielleicht ist es ein Erkan und Stefan Sketch, wer weiß. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Die-Seite. Aber irgendwas war da, irgendwas, wo man dachte, Brille darf man tragen oder die war zu groß oder zu klein. Ich finde das absurd, diese Bestrafung. Neulich wurde auch mein Auto abgeschleppt, zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben. Und das war seltsam, weil erst mal musst du telefonieren, dann musst du die Polizei anrufen, ob es geklaut ist. Dann sagen die, nee. Und dann musst du herausfinden, wo es ist und dann rufst du einfach bei der Stadt Köln an und dann sagt die, wo das hingeschleppt wurde. Dann rufst du da an und dann weißt du, wo dein Auto steht. Dann musste ich ewig mit der Bahn fahren und dann bin ich in Porz ausgestiegen, bin dann da noch, musste ich ewig zu Fuß gehen und dann stand da mein Auto. Und dann habe ich denen das Geld gegeben und dann bin ich mit der Bahn wieder weggefahren. Und das fühlt sich so selten an, wie so eine Erziehungsmethode. Ja, das stimmt schon. N Nimm wir die jetzt weg. Ja, es fühlt sich auch so an, als hätte das Auto... Wir nehmen die jetzt weg und stellen es da hin. Ja, es fühlt sich auch an, als hätte das Auto was falsch gemacht. Ja. Und man musste sein rotziges Kind und das Auto so... Ja, aber das war auch genau meine Haltung. Sorry, es war... Ja, kommt nicht mehr vor. Du kommst jetzt mit. Du kommst jetzt mit nach Hause. Ich habe schon bei einem Gewinnspiel mitgemacht, mein Freund, ja? Wenn ich gewinne, bist du weg. Mama ist stinksauer auf dich! Sorry, sind das Red Bull-Dosen auf dem Rücksitz? Ja, okay, tut mir leid. Du hast viel Pfand im Auto, ne? Viel Pfand! Nicht kritisch gemeint? Wieso nicht kritisch gemeint? Nicht als Kritik gemeint, du bist ein cooler Typ, aber wenn du an dir selber arbeiten willst, vielleicht so die Hälfte deiner Red Bull-Dosen fern aus dem Auto. Ich hab ein Pfandproblem, ja. Du hast ein riesen Pfandproblem. Ja, das Problem ist, dass mein alter Supermarkt hat keinen Pfandautomaten. Und ich weiß nicht, wie ich das Problem in den Griff bekommen soll, wirklich nicht. Ich habe keine Idee, weil ich habe dann überlegt, es gibt ja diese Lieferdienste mittlerweile, die einem Getränke bringen, aber die nehmen nur das mit, was du auch bei Dingen gekauft hast an Pfand. Die nehmen mein Pfand nicht mit. Also habe ich jetzt zu Hause, ich habe einen eigenen Raum mittlerweile, wo sehr viel Pfand drinsteht, diese grossen Wolvikeinschaft mit Wilderflaschen und es ist sehr schnell, nimmt es sehr viel Raum ein. Ich habe kurz eine grosse Küche und die Hälfte davon ist einfach Pfand. Und ich weiß, ich kann das Problem, ich bin ein erwachsener Mensch, ich weiß, dass es ein Problem ist. Und ich weiß, dass wenn ein RTL-Team reinkommt, die ich in so einer Show bin und die mir helfen wollen mit so einer lustigen Popmusik, also im Radio meine Show, meine Wohnung umräumen wollen, aber ich weiss nicht, wer das Problem in den Griff bekommen soll. So eine Intervention, du kommst so nach Hause und die ganzen Pfandflaschen stehen so im Kreis. Einfach, Stefan, du musst dich mehr um uns kümmern. Aber hatte ich tatsächlich, ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal erzählt irgendwann, aber es ist schon sehr, sehr lange her, weil es mir sehr unangenehm ist, aber ich hatte tatsächlich meine Berliner WG mit Lars Paul zusammen, hatten mir enorm viel Pfand, der gesamte Eingangsbereich war voller Pfand und dann hatte ich tatsächlich, ich sag mal Damenbesuch und dann dachte ich mir, fuck, wo, ich kann jetzt nicht den ganzen Tag, komm schon, hey, hey, ja, das ist jetzt vielleicht nett gemeint, aber ihr müsst jetzt nicht, okay, okay. Yes! Yes! Flurrischig wieder da im Besuch, sagte der Mann mit dem Handtuch immer. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, kein Problem, sie kommt in zehn Minuten, ich nehme jetzt einfach den ganzen Pfand vom Flur und tue ihn in das Zimmer von Lars Paulsen. Und wir hatten die in so grossen Ikea-Tüten und wirklich getürmt, wahnsinnig getürmt, wirklich wie so ein Jenga-Turm hochgetürmt und dann tu ich die alle in Lars Paulsen Zimmer und wirklich drei Ikea-Tüten, glaube ich drei oder vier und dann alle zu so einem grossen Turm getürmt, Tür zu, denk mir kein Problem, los geht's, sie kommt an und in dem Moment, in dem wir Hallo sagen, dann höre ich aus dem Zimmer meines Windmars, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klok, klklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklokklok und sie ist wirklich dein Mitbruder nicht da, wir haben einfach nicht gesehen. Und überraschenderweise lief es dann nicht so gut, die Beziehung relativ schnell wieder beendet, aber es hätte einfach nicht sein sollen. Es hat nicht funktioniert. Aber es stand in ihrem Tinder-Profil auch drin, dass sie Pfand hasst oder warum hast du? Ich hasse Pfand. Was macht das für einen Eindruck? Du kommst, gut, denk dann, ich bin sehr reich, weil ich einfach wahnsinnig viel Pfand habe. Du wärst sehr reich, weil du es einfach wegbringst. Kann man zwei Verlobungsringe kaufen von diesen ganzen Pfandflaschen. Ich habe aber immer davon geträumt als Kind, weil ich dachte mir schon relativ schnell, na, Berufsleben, nicht meins. Ich werde kriminell relativ schnell und ich habe mir überlegt, okay, wie kann ich am besten kriminell werden? Und tatsächlich das Beste, was mir eingefallen ist, um kriminell zu sein, war, ich gehe in den Supermarkt und tue volle Flaschen aus dem Supermarkt in den Pfandautomaten. Das war mein Plan. Ich nehme die ganzen vollen Flaschen, tue die in den Pfandautomaten, kriege das Pfand, aber nicht meine Flaschen, die sind im Supermarkt, nehm den Pfand, lass ihm das Geld auszahlen, gewinnen. Ist aber der Pfandautomaten nicht draußen vor dem Supermarkt? Nee, drin, schön drin. War tatsächlich auch mal recht abgesetzt vom Rest. Und ich weiß bis heute, ich habe mich nie getraut, immer wirklich schweißtriefend saß ich davor, mein Fahrrad direkt bereit, Fluchtfahrrad am Start, ich habe mich nie getraut, aber das war immer so, ich dachte immer so, wenn das mit der Mondkarriere nichts wird, mit dem Kindermodeling, wo mein Onkel versucht, mich reinzubringen, wenn das nichts funktioniert, dann kann ich immer noch dem Pfandflaschenbetrug machen. Das hatte ich immer, bis heute fühle ich mich gut. Finde ich gar nicht schlecht. Ich weiß nicht, ob es funktionieren würde, ob der Pfandautomaten nicht sagt, komm, dich so hochvoll. Komm schon, wirklich, wirklich? Es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als der Geruch von Pfandautomaten. Ja, unglaublich. Was da rauskommt für ein Geruch ist der absolute Wahnsinn. Es ist immer so ein Höllenschlund, was aufgeht und dich anpustet. Ich stelle mir doch mal vor, dass da wirklich so ganz mysteriöse Kreaturen da hinten arbeiten, wirklich so Goblins, so vierarmige Kobolde, der wirklich so halb verwachsen ist mit dieser Maschine und dann wirklich so... Ja, was ist denn dieses Geräusch, dieses Krrrr? Ja genau, das ist wie so ein Oger. Ja, was macht das denn? Das ist so eine kleine humanoide Maus, die so auf der Schulter von einem Oger sägt und die Maus dann immer jetzt und dann krrrr macht der Oger einfach so die Krrrr leer und dann einfach krrrr. Noch Tausender, du tausende du bist frei sorg gehorchen und so einfach jeden Tag. Und bin ich denn davor. Ich will immer so schnell sein. Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie so viel Ehrgeiz entwickelt, irgendwo wie einem Pfandautomaten schnell zu sein. Einfach immer, wenn die Flasche reinkommt, direkt die nächste in der Hand haben. Weil ich will einfach der sein, der am souveränsten durchkommt. Und ich will auch der sein, wo keine Flasche wieder zurückkommt. Damit man dann den anderen in der Schlange da hinten den Blick zuwerfen kann. Jetzt mal eine sehr private Frage. Stefan, du hast ja schon viel geteilt, auch aus deinem Privatleben. Eine Frage. Wie oft versuchst du, eine Pfandflasche zurück zu geben bevor du aufgibst bevor der automat sie nicht annimmt wie oft versuch wie oft steckst du die flasche rein bevor du denkst nee die wird einfach nicht angenommen wie oft lustigerweise also ich bevor ich mit dem mit den flaschen aufmache zum Pfandautomaten, sind schon Gedanken sich gemacht worden. Okay, Schritt eins ist schon hinter dir. Also ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass diese Flaschen da auch hingehören und da angenommen werden können. Welche Pfandflaschen werden denn nicht angenommen von Automaten? Die aus fremden Läden tatsächlich, die sind ja knallhart. Nein, das glaube ich. Doch, die sind wirklich knallhart. Die sind wirklich knallhart. Das ist aber gesetzlich, glaube ich, gar nicht möglich. Ja. Dann ist mein Supermarkt illegal. Bitte jetzt einmal verhaften. Ich kann Ihnen die Adresse. Ich weiß, wo er wohnt. Ja, gut, aber ich ziehe es echt durch, dann dreimal. Ja? Ja. Bei mir locker zwölf Mal. Ich will es nicht einsehen. Ich denke mir, das ist eine Flasche. Das ist ein Flaschenautomal. Ich versuche manchmal so zu werfen, weil das ist wie dieses kleine Fließband. Ich denke mir so, man kann doch einfach da rein, weil ich will die primär loswerden. Mir geht es gar nicht um das Geldbetrag, ich will die primär, dass der Oger da hinten die zerknüllen kann. Es ist ein elaborierter Müllabend. Was wird da gemacht, wird die zerpresst schon? Ich glaube, die Restflüssigkeit so rausgedrückt.
Und dann hast du da wirklich so, wie diese Sarlacc-Pit-Kreatur.
Ja!
Wo dann einfach noch die letzten drei Tropfen Spezi so...
Genau, so eine Zunge und Tentakel kommen dann so raus.
Ja, ja, ich glaube schon, oder?
Dass die dann so...
Das letzte Rest noch mal rausdrücken?
Glaube ich auch.
Oder einfach dann so sich reindrücken?
Es ist ja eine normale Spezi, hallo?
Ganz normal, die ist ja noch nicht vermischt worden. Nee, ist schon widerlich, so Phantatomaten sind echt kacke. Phantatomaten? Phantatomaten. Ach, ich dachte, Phantatomaten. Ich dachte, wenn man Phantatomaten trinkt wiederum geil. Ich dachte jetzt kurz, wenn man Phanta zu lange stehen lässt, wachsen da so kleine Tomaten drin oder irgendwie sowas. Diese habe ich noch nicht, diese Erfahrung habe ich noch nicht gemacht. Aber wenn du Eistee zu lange stehen lässt, dann macht da Schimmel. Ja, da bildet sich so eine Kultur. Aber du hast so Schimmel, Inseln, wo ich mir denke, what? Also die haben eine Kreaturpflanzen-Hybrid, die keine Wurzeln hat, die frei schwimmt im Wasser. Das ist wie bei Man in Black, wenn die diesen Spint aufmachen, diese Kultur, die dich anbietet. Das ist, wenn du den typischen Lidl-Eistee eine Woche lang stehen lässt und dann machst du oben das Ding auf und dann kommt so ein Volk und das bittet dich an. Lidl, Lidl, fängt dich an anzubeten. Aber du denkst ja halt auch so, naja, wenn ich den rausnehme. Ich meine, was ist denn, ich sehe ja ganz genau, wo der Schimmel ist. Ich glaube, du siehst nicht ganz genau immer, wo der Schimmel ist. Vor allem Idee, der frisst ja den Zucker. Kann man so nicht kostengünstig Diätprodukte herstellen, dass man die einfach so voll schimmeln lässt, Schimmel weg? Aber ich meine, irgendjemand hat den Schimmelkäse erfunden. Ja genau, ohne Scheiss, wir erfinden den Eistee-Schimmel. Schimmel-Eistee, ja. Ich bin mir sicher, wenn man das reinmischt, vielleicht ist es unglaublich lecker.
Das traut sich nur jemand. Ihr habt zu viel Angst, ihr habt zu viel Ekel, der Ekel steht euch im Weg. Einfach mal macht mal einen Tag pro Woche ohne Ekel. Ich habe wirklich mal gehört, ein sehr enges Familienmitglied hat sehr lange Maschinen hergestellt, für Brauereien und Abfüllanlagen für Coca-Cola etc. Und ich habe mal gehört, dass König Pilsner unfassbar verschimmelte Anlagen hat, Brauereianlagen. Und viele sagen immer, König Pilsner hat diesen tollen Eigengeschmack. Und ich habe häufig gehört von Leuten, die in dieser Firma gearbeitet haben, dass es daran liegt, weil die teilweise einfach, das kann man aber nicht vorstellen, da gibt es auch Gesundheitsamt und so was. Istaja, ist das nicht so mit Hefe und alles pilzig? Ich meine, das ist ja ein neutraler Ausdruck oder so. Aber ich kannte mal jemanden, Lars Pausen, der, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, der hatte mal einen Nebenjob in der Brauerei und dessen Aufgabe war es, diese riesigen Brauereitanks von innen zu putzen. Der ist da reingeklärt und hat es von innen geputzt und
ihm ist dann immer ganz schwindelig geworden von diesen ganzen Chemikalien, aber er kam ja nicht raus.
Also so ist Lars Paulsen entstanden, wie ihr ihn heute kennt, ja vom Alter 14 bis 17.
Er ist der Oger in diesen Automaten vielleicht auch.
Das kann gut sein, dass sie so entstehen vielleicht. Ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig.
Ich habe mir letztens auch eine völlig randome Doku zu Jägermeister angeschaut, weil ich dachte mir einfach so, was ist das eigentlich? Und das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, hatten das Problem, dass irgendwie fast der ein riesiges Fass Jägermeister ausgelaufen wäre. Die haben diese riesigen Turmhöhen, hohe Fässer und dann haben die gesagt, so völlig humorlos, ja, wenn jetzt hier alles, wenn wir jetzt hier knietief in Jägermeister stehen würden, Lebensgefahr. Und ich gucke mir das so an, denke mir, das klingt so, als ob die Doku irgendeinen dramaturgischen Aufbau braucht. Ja, wirklich, und dann denke ich, Lebensgefahr, also gut, ja, wenn der das sagt, ich meine, der wird das Szenario wahrscheinlich oft in seinem Kopf durchgespielt haben. Was passiert, wenn so ein Ding bricht? Und dann kannst du ja nicht die Tür aufmachen.
Du kannst ja nicht zehn Millionen Liter Jägermeister schön die Grundschulstraße runtergießen lassen,
schön irgendwie die Kinderwasserschlacht gerade, irgendwie so Schneeballschlacht.
Was sind die Doku? Flutwelle Jägermeister ein.
Was war denn die Doku-Idee?
Jägermeister.
Die Entstehungsgeschichte von Jägermeister.
Nee, so, was ist das, was machen die, was machen die da so?
Werbung, wer schaut.
Es kann auch sein, dass es so ein Pop-up war.
Image-Film.
Ich weiß nicht genau, aber ich habe mich, es ist ja immer so stocklangweilig, so Dokumentation,
da muss man dann immer so, ah, und dann, oh, jetzt Alarm, Alarm, oh, was ist los, ja, ein bisschen zu viel Alkohol,
und dann, ja, passt schon, jeder trinkt einen Schluck und dann passt es irgendwie so.
Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung.
Was ist denn der Germeister drin, weißt du irgendwas, jetzt mehr über den?
Geheime Kräuter, geheime Kräuter.
Wow, geile Doku.
Vielen Dank. und dann, ja, passt schon, jeder trinkt einen Schluck und dann passt es irgendwie so. Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Was ist denn der Meister drin, weißt du irgendwas jetzt mehr über den? Geheime Kräuter, geheime Kräuter. Wow, geile Doku. Wie lange war die Doku? Und dann haben die diese ganzen Säcke Kräuter angeliefert und dann stand da irgendwie so drauf, so Kümmel, Kardamon und so. Und waren verrixelt. Ne, haben die da so wirklich diese Namen von den Kräutern abgefilmt und dann hieß es, die Geheimere, die Rezeptur ist streng geheim, einfach so. Alle so, wo er stand stand da noch gerade. Einfach so Kümmel. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert. Ich habe mir die Doku angeschaut und ich bin nicht klüger. Wie macht man aus Kräutern sowas unglaublich Leckeres? Ich habe keine Ahnung, in meinem Leben noch nie. Ich habe schon die Werbung funktioniert, aber. Keine Ahnung. Was mich aber fasziniert, ist, dass das ja nicht gefriert. Nee. Alkohol gefriert nicht. Ich weiß, ich glaube,, ich komme ein bisschen auf die Konzentration an. Aber ich habe auch, glaube ich, seit dem Beginn meiner, als ich in die Wohnung gezogen bin, habe ich sofort eine Jägermeisterflasche geschenkt bekommen, war im Eisfach und die ist auch immer noch drin, glaube ich. Und da hat sich noch keine Kultur gebildet. Das wäre geil, wenn die anders wäre, auch viel glücklicher, als diese Eistee-Kultur. Oder so eine bodenständige Kultur, so Jägersmann, Heizmann. Oder so eine Ibiza-Kultur, so eine feierwütige Miniatur, Ibiza-Welt. Ja, als diese Eistilkultur. Oder so eine bodenständige Kultur. So Jägersmann, Heizmann, Heizmann. Oder so eine Ibiza-Kultur, so eine feierwütige Miniatur Ibiza-Welt. Ja, das stimmt. So eine Lightshow auch. Glaubst du, wir sind alle nur eine Kultur in der Jägermeisterflasche von einem Alien? Kann das sein? Ja. Ich glaube, wir sind nicht Jägermeister, ich glaube, wir sind so, weiss ich nicht, Milch. So ein Sangria eher. Wir sind so Jahrmilch, glaube ich. So eine haltbare Jahrmilch einfach, die man mal vergessen hat. Oh, die hatte ich noch. Aber auch nicht Vollmilch. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Das würden wir merken, glaube ich. Nee, stimmt schon. Also Klimawandel, klar. Klar. Aber! Klar. Nee! Glaubt ihr nicht, dass wenn wir es jetzt einfach richtig komplett hardcore verbocken, wirklich so volle Lotte, einfach so kein Weg zurück. Meinst vielleicht die chance besteht dass irgendwie so aliens kommen und sagen so alles klar hei leider falsch gemacht wir drehen mal co2 bei euch runter zack versucht es noch mal wäre das nicht eine gute möglichkeit vielleicht aliens anzulocken ist so hardcore zu verkacken dass sie irgendwann kommen und sagt menschen was habt ihr denn da gemacht sondern einfach sagen, hier kommt, jeder nimmt eine Schaufel, wir machen den CO2 weg. Das ist ja aus dem Straßenverkehr, wenn man Probleme hat, dann kommen Leute und wollen helfen. Ja, so ein Reset. Dass alle Menschen kommen und überschwemmen einen mit ihrer Hilfe. Ja, und die machen einfach so einen Schnipp. Nein, das passiert nicht. Klar, die kommen da und machen einen Schnipp und dann Reset. Ich glaube, wir verpassen gerade die grösste Chance der Menschheit, Kontakt zu Aliens zu schaffen. Wirklich.
Du weißt es ganz genau. Ja, wenn wir es schaffen, dass man dann in so einen gelesenen Kreis kommt.
Die Lektion hat jedes Kind gemacht. Wenn dein Zimmer nicht aufgeräumt ist, schimpft dich deine Mutter. Wenn dein Zimmer so richtig fucking hardcore nicht aufgeräumt ist, räumt deine Mutter für dich auf. Ja, aber wenn du selber aufräumst, fährt deine Mutter mit dir ins Phantasialand.
Und das Phantasialand ist ja sinnbildlich gesprochen der galaktische Club, in dem wir wollen. Verstehst du? Ich glaube, wenn man dieses Bottleneck-Klimawandel überlebt und Überbevölkerung usw. Das ist der Test. Das sind so ein paar Bottlenecks, da muss man durch. Und dann kommen Aliens und sagen, herzlichen Glückwunsch, du bist jetzt dabei. Die sind alle grün, wir sind alle blau, die haben Riesenköpfe, sieht ultra lustig aus und so weiter. Du bist einfach in so einem geilen Club. Menschen, was ist euer grösstes Kunstwerk? Musik, Musik, Musik, wir sehen uns in hundert Jahren. Fuck, wir haben's verbockt. Wir haben's verbockt. Warum hat Clouseau unser Stellvertreter, oder wer war das? Nummer 100 Musik? Bosse. Bosse, alles klar, sorry. Musik, Musik, Musik, Musik, Aliens. Aliens, Aliens. Glaubst du, die Aliens werden so aussehen wie wir? Ja, genau so. Wie du. Alle wie du. Weil die sind ja wahrscheinlich dann... Ach, wie lustig wäre es, wenn die alle aussehen wie Michael Jackson oder sowas. Einfach alle genau so aussehen wie einer, den wir kennen. Und niemand traut sich zu sagen, dass sie eine Alienrasse ist. Ja, und dann so guckt man in deren Keller, bitte. Sorry, ganz kurz, bevor wir weiterreden. Aber so einfach, weil ich meine, die werden ja schon Humor haben, oder? Also wenn man sich irgendwas vorstellt, dann denkt man immer, ja klar, die haben unsere Wissenschaft nur besser. Die haben unsere Ökosphäre nur besser. Warum nicht sagen, die haben unseren Humor, die sind einfach saulustig und
einfach mal pranken uns einfach die ganze Zeit und die können sich ja so gestaltwandeln und kommen dann so irgendwie als, wie gesagt, als Michael Jackson auf die Erde, einfach aus Scheiss. Weil warum denn nicht, was machen wir denn mit Tieren? Wir binden denen so ein Lätzchen um und lachen uns kaputt, dass das nicht die Katze Down-Syndrom hat. Als ob die Aliens sich auch einfach sagen würden.
Aber dann stand die da vom schiefen Turm von Pisa und hat, ha ha ha, guck dir den Trottel an, guck dir in die Hand. Könnte ich mich drüber beömmeln. Der trinkt Eis. Oder wir schaffen halt auch nur nicht so viel als Gesellschaft, weil wir Humor haben. Und irgendwann, du musst Humor ablegen, um wirklich was erreichen zu können. Weiß ich nicht. These. Weiß ich nicht, kann schon sein. Unproved These. Ich glaube, die haben richtig, die lollen richtig ab da rum in der Galaxie, die sind richtig von Uranus, wahrscheinlich so das erste Geräusch, was man hört, so. Was war das? Was war das? Machen wir das Mikroskop dahin, Mikrofon, Mikrofon, Teleskop, Mikroskop. Ruf mal das Mikrofon an. Wer sind Sie? Das war eine neue Arbeitskollegin und die hatte neulich den Schlüssel verloren. Und ich habe den Gag gemacht, den ich immer mache, ruf doch einfach mal an. Wenn Leute Dinge verlieren, sage ich, ruf doch einfach mal darauf an. Ich habe meine Brille hingelegt, ja, ruf doch mal darauf an. Unser Kind ist jetzt seit zwei Monaten vermisst. Ruf darauf an! Ruf darauf an! Geil, ja stimmt.
Ist kein guter Gag, aber jeder hat diese Gags, die man selber mag.
Reflex-Gags, jeder hat Reflex-Gags.
Reflex-Gags.
Naja, uns fällt noch ein besserer Titel ein.
Aber ein guter Podcast.
Und sie hat gesagt, ah ja, gute Idee, und hat den Schlüssel angerufen und hat geklingelt.
Wow!
What?
Ja, sie hat den Schlüssel angerufen und da war so ein Chipingerufen und hat geklingelt. Wow! What? Ja, sie hat ihren Schlüssel eingerufen und da war so ein Chip dran und der hat geklingelt
und dann hat sie ihren Schlüssel gefunden.
Ja, kommst zurück, ne? Ja, genau, ja.
Ich war schon ein bisschen wütend, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich war kurz in der Tanke.
Nee, ich mein's ernst, komm zurück, alles klar, bis heute Abend, tschüss.
Und es hat wirklich funktioniert.
Der hat einfach ihren Schlüssel eingerufen, oder was?
Ja! Und der hat dann geblinkt, oder was? Nee, gepiept. Schlüssel. Krass. Du Trott, lass mich verloren. Verlor, verloren, verloren, hier, hier, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe! Ich würde lieber Dinge aufschliessen, als hier um Boden zu leben. Ach ja. Ach, Schlüssel. Aber irgendwann haben die einen eigenen Wildensschlüssel. Nee. Kann auch sein. Nee, kann nicht sein.
Aber es gibt auch schon so Schlüssel, die merken, wenn man betrunken ist, dann kann man nicht mehr Auto fahren.
Das Auto merkt das.
Das Auto merkt das?
Mir kommt dann, nee, nicht mehr mein Auto, aber bei Bekannten kommt so eine Kaffeetasse, also Pausentasse.
Da soll man Pause machen, wenn du es merkt, dass du langsam immer von der Strasse abkommst.
Und ich auch sage, das ist aber, also da sollte das davor, gab es doch schon Red Flags. Also wenn man von der Strasse abkommt. Und ich auch sage, das ist aber, also, da sollte das, davor gab es doch schon Red Flags, also wenn man von der Strasse abkommt, ist das schon ziemlich gefährlich. Ist das nicht eine gute Möglichkeit für Drug Placement, einfach so, jetzt ein Militakaffee und Sie müssen nicht sterben? McDonald's, uns gibt's überall, Airways, Sie haben keine andere Wahl. Jetzt eine Zigarette, die Deutsche Bahn. Aber ich dachte, es gibt einen Schlüssel, wenn man so drauf drückt, dann sagt er, nope, nope mein ich. Ich weiss nicht. Wäre ein gutes Startup eigentlich, oder? Ja, wer würde das kaufen? Das kann deine Black Mirror Episode sein. Ja gut, der Werbeclaim ist, wenn sie fucking unverantwortlich sind, kaufen sie diesen Schlüssel. Die gehen weg wie nix wahrscheinlich. Ihr denkt sich, ich will nie betrunken Auto fahren, oder? Bist du schon mal so richtig hacke-dicht Auto gefahren? Nee, nee, nee, hacke-dicht nicht. Aber ich bin nicht stolz darauf, dass ich schon mal vielleicht mit, weiss ich nicht, ein Bier zu viel oder so schon mal nochmal nach Hause. Aber dann damals halt, wenn man dann auf dem Land wohnt und sonst nicht echt ewig nach Hause laufen müsste. Und dann habe ich auch damals, das ist von mir selber gerechtfertigt,
so wenn ich jetzt hier fünf Stunden nach Hause gehe,
ist das doch auch gefährlicher, als jetzt einfach ganz langsam nach Hause zu fahren.
Ja, don't drink a drive, müssen wir jetzt rechtlich hier an der Stätte sagen.
Nee, muss man sagen, stimmt nicht weh, bin auch nicht stolz drauf, ist ganz, ganz doof.
Sollte man auch vielleicht nicht im Podcast erzählen, aber well, that happened.
Naja, gerade auf dem Land, da musst du ja auch nicht immer die Strasse treffen, da gibt es
wie viele Felder und dann fährst du da durch, das passt schon.
Du hast mal die spannende Frage gestellt, ob man besoffen reiten darf noch.
Ja.
Und ja, darf man.
Ja, tatsächlich, Reiter zählen verkehrsrechtlich als Fußgänger.
Ja, weil das Pferd reitet dann keine Schlangenlinien und das Pferd läuft auch nicht dann von der
Strasse weg, weil das Pferd ja auch denkt.
Und wenn du das nicht mehr so gut ist, dann so clever, dass es wie ein Pferd gilt, dass Autos sind wie Fussgänger? Verstehst du? Das stimmt schon. Sobald man selbstfahrende Autos hat, sind alle komplett nicht einfach. Nun Tesla ist doch auch cleverer als ein Pferd. Hm, das wäre eine Sendung, die ich mir anschauen würde.
Tesla gegen Pferd. Tesla gegen Pferd.
Einfach so zehn Challenges.
Nee, nein.
Tesla versus Pferd versus Simon.
Besser, keine Challenge, einfach ein Ring.
Und wir stellen einfach ein Tesla hin und ein Pferd.
Und Jung und Klaas, einfach mal ausreizt.
Ja, und Janine Michael so moderiert, und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert.
Einfach mal, was passiert. Weiß ich nicht. Finde ich eine gute Idee, aber da hat natürlich die Pferdelobby viel zu sagen. Klar, die wäre natürlich... Tesla-Lobby ist auch stark. Es gibt wahnsinnig viele Pferde in Deutschland, kein Witz. Richtig viele Pferde. Bei uns gab es auch immer einen, der Pferde hatte, der immer ohne weiteres mit einem Pferd zur Party kommen können und dann nach Hause. Was mehr geil ist, wie so im alten, wilden Westen kannst du das anbinden, dann irgendwo über so einen Holzpfahl, und dann kannst du feiern gehen.
Wenn da hast du irgendwie Spaß, irgendwie keine Ahnung,
machst dann mit Melanie rum und dann schaust du zu deinem Pferd und das Pferd nur so, hallo.
Du bist langsam nach Hause, mein Freund.
Noch fünf Minuten, noch fünf Minuten.
Wir müssen los, du.
Ich habe morgen Stalldienst.
Melanie, ich habe die Melanie hier. Und dann kannst du, das Pferd ist dann auch sauer, weil du Melanie mitnimmst auf dem Pferd. Ich meine, warum muss man sich auf dem Pferd nicht anschnallen? War einfach mal in die Runde gefragt, warum muss man sich im Auto anschnallen auf dem Pferd nicht? Warum muss das Pferd selber keinen Helm tragen? Oder so viel... Ein Pferd hat vier Knie, warum nicht vier Knieschoner? Ja, weil ein Pferd ist doch schneller als ein Fahrrad. Eher. Safety first, weil die toll aussehen wollen mit ihrer Mähne. Ja, stimmt schon, die müssen ja immer so einen Pferdeschwanz tragen. Demütigend für ein Pferd. Stimmt schon, aber tatsächlich legendärerweise, ja, Genghis Khan hat sich für unsterblich erklärt und ist gestorben, weil er vom Pferd gefallen ist. Das wäre nicht passiert mit Gurtpflicht in der alten Mongolei. Wäre nicht passiert. Oder Helm, der einfach Genghis Khan Helm tragen könnte. Ich glaube, der hat den Helm auch. Meinst du? Ja, aber die hatten, glaube ich, auch so Hörner, die Mongolen so, und dann ist er so stecken geblieben. Oh. Ich glaube, das war keine gute Idee. Hörner hat ja keine gute Idee. Hat der Wikinger wirklich so Hörner am Kopf? Nee, ich glaube gerade der Wikinger nicht irgendwie. Das war dann... Aber irgendjemand hatte Hörner irgendwie, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Aber es ist an sich schon eine gute Idee. Die Frage ist halt, ob die damit auch gekämpft haben so. Mit dem Horn. Weil ich meine, warum denn nicht? Weil es ist ja immer ein Blöd so, du hast Schwert, Schild und dann Schwert auf Schild, Schwert auf Schild und dann? Horn, Horn. Zack! Aber wäre dann nicht geil, einfach nur ein Horn, aber so eine große Spitze. Ja, weil ich meine, es muss ja auch, sag ich mal, so Innovatoren im Mittelalter gegeben haben, die sagen, Leute, ich habe die beste Waffe der Welt, riesiger Stachel direkt auf dem Helm, ich renne vorneweg, vor der ganzen Armee, warte, warte, warte, vor der Armee renne ich weg, kopfüber, warte, warte, warte, kopfüber renne ich in die feindliche Armee rein, zack, spießt den Hunden auf, keine Chance. Handgeklapper. Sehr höflich immer, das Mittelalter war sehr viel Golf gespielt im Mittelalter auch. Aber es stimmt, wir kennen ja die Ritter immer nur so als cool, mit der coolen Rüstung oder so, die hatten bestimmt auch viele richtig beschissen Ideen. Mittelalter waren die wahnsinnig doof, habe ich jetzt gehört, die haben irgendwann mal herausgefunden, die haben halt Papier über Feuer gehalten und dann ist es geflogen, weil warme Luft ihr trägt.
Die dachten aber, das wäre der Rauch. Und dann haben die irgendwann mal die Leute in brennendes Papier gesetzt, und zwar weil die den Heissluftballon erfinden wollten. Die wussten noch nicht, was sie erfinden, die haben nur gedacht, brennendes Papier fliegt auf eine Art. Und dann haben die einfach so, das war glaube ich in Frankreich, Gefangene aus der Bastille genommen und in so ein brennendes Papierding gesteckt, angesteckt und es ist nicht alle verbrannt, tragische Geschichte, irgendwann haben die immer weiter experimentiert mit Gefangenen und irgendwann hatten die dann so einen Korb und dann hatten die auch Feuer und dann hatten die so ein großes Papiergebilde, wie man das heute kennt und dann sind die geflogen. Und dann sind die aber nie wieder aufgetaucht und die haben das als Beweis dafür genommen, dass es funktioniert. Das war der erste Heissluftballon. Du erwartest nicht so, ja okay und dann flieiegt der und was dann, ja keine Ahnung, dann fliegen sie weg. Das haben die dann als Beweis genommen, dass es funktioniert. Und dann hat dieser Baron, hat sich das selber auch da hingesetzt und so weiter, hat das mit so einem Ballonbauern dann gemacht und der Ballonbauer, da hat das funktioniert, dann sind die halt, das habe ich nämlich auch herausgefunden, Ballons können nämlich nicht lenken, die fliegen, das war auch immer eine Frage, die uns gestellt haben, die fliegen einfach mit dem Wind und kommen irgendwo dann wieder runter. So und dann war dieser Typ, der damals geherrscht hat, war so zufrieden damit und fand das so toll, dass er die einfach geadelt hat, die Leute, die diese Ballons gebaut haben. Und dann gehört denen die Länderei und es gilt bis heute dieses Gesetz. Und ein Kumpel von mir ist neulich mit dem Ballon geflogen, weil er gewonnen hat in einem Gewinnspiel. Ah, schau mal! Denn seine Freundin war die einzige, die mitgemacht hat beim Big Mac Heissluftballon Gewinnspiel von McDonalds. Ja, es gibt jetzt einen Big Mac Heissluftballon, das ist einfach ein grosser Big Mac. Ah! Und das ist ein Heissluftballon und die fliegen dann manchmal rum. Seine Freundin hat da mitgemacht und mein Freund musste dann da mitfliegen. Er war nicht so mega begeistert, mit dem Big Mac Ballon rumzufliegen, aber das war dann halt das Gewinnspiel. Danach wurde er auch dann, ihm gehören jetzt glaube ich die Ländereien von Elmshorn bis Wedel um Hamburg herum. Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist ein Problem, ein Big Mac-Heistophilong, du wirst halt sehr hungrig irgendwann. Ich glaube, ich kann mir nur eine gewisse Zeit lang ein Big Mac anschauen, ohne ein Big Mac zu essen und sagen, Leute, das ist einfach keine gute Idee. Ich fand das fantastisch. Und er meinte auch, dass der Pilot super angepisst war. Der war halt einfach so, ich kenne das, das ist so typisch deutsch auch. Seine Aufgabe ist es, Heissbussballon Leute rumzukutschieren, und das ist eigentlich eine ganz tolle Aufgabe, eine super schöne, spaßige Aufgabe, aber seine erste SMS war, ja, morgen geht es um sechs los, ihr könnt früher da sein, aber keine Minute zu spät, so, und danach haben wir viel Spaß mit unserem Big Mac Ballon, das war die Ansprache. Sonst was, sonst fliegst du ohne uns los. Da sind wir auch noch uns los, ja. Und dann sind wir da hin und dann hat er irgendwann, war dann klar, also dann fliegst du mit dem Wind und man weiss nicht genau, wo man landet. Dann guckt man dann, unten ist dann immer so ein Auto, was hinterher fährt, was sich dann wieder einsammelt. Wirklich? Ja, unten fährt ein Auto mit, was guckt, wo der Ballon gerade ist und dann einigt man sich zusammen auf den Landeplatz und so. Und dann hat er irgendwann gesagt, ja, gleich landen wir. Naja, was heißt landen? Ballons kippen eigentlich immer um. Also wir werden alle aufeinander fallen, das war sein Wortlaut. Wir werden alle aufeinander fallen, weil es fällt immer um. Weil du kannst im Ballon nicht gut landen. Und dann habe ich auch gedacht, warum nennt er sich dann Pilot? Alles was er kann, er kann weder lenken, er kann die Höhe minimal beeinflussen mit seinem Feuer, aber das können auch Freunde und die Freundin, die dabei drin waren. Warum nennt er sich Pilot? Aber er hat auch gesagt, er ist eher Ballonfahrer, aber auch das finde ich auch alles noch ein bisschen zu hochgestochen. Naja, jedenfalls fährt der Big Mac dann rum und irgendwann landet, beschliesst der Big Mac zu landen und dann landet dieser Riesen-Big Mac und fällt dann um. Und dann kam auch direkt so ein Passant, der ist da hingelaufen, und mein Kumpel hat gar nicht verstanden, warum dann immer Passanten kommen, aber der Ballonfahrer war dann so sehr gechillt und wusste genau, ah okay, das ist wieder so einer, weil es kommt immer vor, immer wenn ein Ballon landet, laufen Passanten dahin, weil sie denken, dass der Ballon abgestürzt wird. Weil Ballons immer so landen, es sieht immer aus wie ein Kampf gegen die Gravitation und den der Ballon verliert, aber dann sieht es immer so aus, als ob der abgestürzt ist. Bei jeder normalen Ballonlandung kommen Passanten angerannt und wollen helfen. Aber das heißt, du kannst ganz normal Samstagnachmittags in deinem Garten sitzen und denkst dir nichts und siehst einfach so einen riesigen Big Mac auf die zukommen, die einfach gnadenlos auf dich zuwählen ist, so Rita, oder einfach so watz direkt ins Gesicht. Du kannst nichts dagegen machen. Geil, ich erinnere dir mal vor, man kennt das ja manchmal, man hat Hunger und dann betet man so, jetzt was Geiles zu essen und dann kommt so ein Big Mac angeflogen. Ja, aber das war schon ganz lustig, glaube ich, für ihn und ich habe viele Fragen beantwortet bekommen, weil ich wusste zum Beispiel nicht, wie Ballons der Umwelt ausgesetzt sind, aber tatsächlich zu 100 Prozent. Wirklich, die können nichts machen. Ein Rabe kommt tot. Einfach Rabe hat Hunger, zack, fliegt einfach da durch. Ja, und dann sind die so in einer Kuhherde gelandet, das war auch ein Problem dann. Die werden sich auch gewundert haben. Tierki, da bist du wieder. Wir haben ja gehört, du bist jetzt bei McDonalds, aber das... Aber so ein grosses Burger-Patty auch landet in der Kuhherde, diese Ironie ist auch... Ja, ja. Puh! Kritisch. Ich hab letztens, ich konnte es gar nicht fassen, ich hab einen Zeppelin gesehen. Ja! Zeppelin! Hast du ihn auch gesehen? Ja! Zeppelin! Ich schau aus dem Fenster, ich schau halt in den Himmel, wie man in den Himmel schaut, und denke mir, what? Zehn Zeppelin und er hat direkt, er hat ein bisschen gestylt, muss man sagen, der wusste schon, dass er ein ziemlich cooler Zeppelin ist, der hat direkt über, also so in meinem Blickfeld, hat er so eine richtige, so einen Drift gemacht, weißt du, wie irgendwie die Too Fast, Too Furious? Ja, die driften nämlich rum und das Geile ist, du hast in Köln ein hohes Gebäude und hast den Fernsehturm. Und aus meiner Perspektive sah es, da habe ich gerade so ein Telefoninterview gegeben, lustigerweise, über die Serie. Und dann hat die mich was gefragt und ich habe einfach diesen Zeppelin gesehen. Und vorm Fenster, ich sehe nur dieses hohe Haus und diesen Zeppelin. Und es sah ohne Scheisse, es sah crazy, als ob der da reinfliegt. Und ich habe dann diesem Typen nicht mehr geantwortet. Und er hat die ganze Zeit gesagt, Herr Tietze, Herr Tietze, sind Sie noch da? Und ich sass einfach da und habe diesen Zeppelin gesehen. Und dann dachte ich mir aber, was soll passieren? Weil Zeppelin ist halt heiße Luft. Das ist nicht wie 9-11, das wäre so German 9-11. Ja, und er ist einfach so, er dortzt so dagegen und fliegt dann wieder rückwärts zurück. Zurück? Das ist ja der lustigste Terroranspruch. Verdammt nochmal! Aller Zeiten. Deutsches ISIS so. Ja. Al-Qaida bekennt sich augenrollend. Ja, waren wir. Ja, fuck, waren wir. Sorry. Wir wussten nicht. Keine Erfahrung mit Zeppelin. Aber, damit ihr es jetzt wisst, falls ihr tatsächlich mal einen Zeppelin in Not seht, 188188, die Zeppelin-Hotline. Oh, geulich im Himmel. Falls ihr nicht wisst, einfach mal durchklingeln, die kommen mit einem riesigen Lasso und dann fangen die wieder ein. Und dann fliegen sie mal weg am Lasso. Ziehen den dann so auf den Boden runter. Zeppelin ist alles falsch. Zeppelin ist großartig. Hintenburg, ja, echt total faszinierend. Gibt es da einen Film eigentlich über die Hindenburg? Nee, aber es gibt ja bestimmt ja doch auf jeden Fall. Allein die Geschichte, was mich total fasziniert hat, auf der Hindenburg gab es ein einziges Feuerzeug. Ja schlimm genug, es gab einen Feuerhüter. Nee, es gab sogar einen Raucherraum, wo ich dachte, der muss der, sorry, was ist oben uns da rum? Es ist sehr dekadent. Ja, es ist wirklich, ist auch eine doofe Idee. Das ist so wie der Eisraum in der Titanic, einfach so. Wirklich, müssen wir jetzt Eis essen in der Titanic? Und du hast nur Raucherraum, aber du hast den Hüter der Flamme. Du hast nur einen mit einem Feuerzeug, der muss allen... Allein das ist doch schon Sitcom-Bürg. Hat der denn Mist gebaut? Ich will sie sich nicht in die Schuhe ziehen, das ganze Beweismaterial ist leider verbrannt, oder glücklicherweise verbrannt. Schade, um die vier Menschen leben, aber ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute da drin waren. Die waren ja randvoll mit Menschen, also dieser ganze Ballon war dicht gedrängt mit Menschen. Die hatten 27 Schlafkajüten. Aber dass sie keine Rettungs... Im Ernst, das war wie ein Kreuzfahrtschiff. Aber warum haben die keine Rettungsboote? Wie Boote? Kleine Rettungszeppeline. Und die einfach so dann wegfliegen. Das verstehe ich auch bis heute nicht. Warum man im Fliegen, warum nicht jeder... Scheiße auf diese Wasserwesten, Rettungswesten, zieht doch jedem einfach diese... Das nimmt doch ordentlich viel Platz weg, so ein Fallschirm an. Ja, oder einfach jeder kriegt kleine Flügel. Kleine Flügel. So dass wenn es wirklich scheiße läuft, dann einfach so jeder für sich einfach packt. Aber wie geil das ist, wenn du einen Flugzeugabsturz hast und dann kommen einfach so 280 Fallschirme landen und dann sagt niemand mehr, oh, tragische Tragödie und alle sagen, wow, das ist super schön. Ja, ist mal eine Überlegung wert. So bunt, so eine bunte Menschenmasse landet mit lachenden Gesichtern. Ja, wir fliegen ja dieses Jahr noch gemeinsam. Wir fliegen gemeinsam nach New York. Wir können da vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen pitchen, wir können da noch mal ein bisschen sagen, hey, kurze Idee. Oder einer hat so seinen privaten Fallschirm dabei, einfach so. Sitzt er so mit Helm und mit so einer GoPro dann einfach so in erster Reihe. Man weiß nicht, was kommt, man weiß nicht, was kommt. Warum, und dann würde ich auch fragen, warum tragen Sie den Helm? Ich darf nichts verraten, aber ich sage mal. Ja, aber warum tragen Sie den Helm, wenn Sie sich, dass Sie einen Fallschirm anhaben. Nein, nein, nein, nein, winken Sie immer für den Livestream. Hallo! Aber was passiert, ja, warum trägt man einen Helm? Tragen einen Fallschirm, springen aber einen Helm? Ich glaube ja... Weil der hilft dann auch nicht mehr. Wenn man schief geht, hilft doch der Helm nicht. Für die Frisur, einfach so, das macht dann die Haare nicht. Fürs GoPro-Video, für Instagram. Ja, da hast du so ein cooles GoPro-Video, aber es sieht dann aus wie so ein brennender Busch.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Was ist dein
Tour-Fazit?
Puh.
Wo hat es dir am besten gefallen?
Also wirklich auf der, ich würde mal sagen, Top 3
auf jeden Fall, Platz Nummer 3
ganz klar Wien. Wien?
Grossartig. Platz Nummer 2 München.
Ja. Platz Nummer 1 müsste ich jetzt, wenn ich jetzt mal... Hannover war auch gut, sagen wir mal so. Hannover war auch gut, aber auf Platz eins ganz klar für mich Leipzig. Leipzig war auch auf der Seite. Ganz klar, muss sein, muss sein. Leipzig ist toll, ist eine super Stadt. Toller Baumarkt, richtig toller Baumarkt. Ja, da bin ich richtig gut. Mehr können wir nicht sagen von der Stadt, aber wir sind sehr viel rumgekommen, wir haben ganz viele von unseren Hörern getroffen, auch nach der Show, viele Hände geschüttelt, viele Fotos gemacht. Sau viele Hände geschüttelt. Tolle Fotos gemacht, tatsächlich, was mich immer noch irritiert hat, eine junge Dame wollte ein Foto mit uns machen und dann ging ihr Handy nicht.
Und dann habe ich angeboten, ja, dann mache ich ein Foto mit meinem Handy und gib mir deine E-Mail-Adresse.
Sie haben dein Handy.
Nee, und schick deine E-Mail-Adresse an unsere Webseite und wir schicken dir die Bilder zu.
Bis heute kam die nicht, die Mail.
Einfach so, nö, will die nicht. Das heißt, irgendwann dachte ich mir, veröffentlich die einfach so, ob sie das will oder nicht, die werden in die Öffentlichkeit kommen.
Also okay.
Aber na ja, falls du das hörst. Ich glaube, viele machen auch nur aus Höflichkeit ein Foto mit uns, so einfach, dass man sagt, so jetzt komm. Ich hoffe, wir stehen da und niemand kommt, das wäre auch peinlich. Ja, das wäre sehr unangenehm. Also bitte kommt gleich noch rum und macht Fotos. Also mir war Zeit für Spaß gemacht, es war cool, alle mal kennenzulernen, alle, weiß nicht, viele. Ich glaube, mittlerweile müssten wir alle durchhaben. Ich glaube, wir haben alle mal gesehen. Wir haben viele gesehen, viele Geschenke, viele mitbringen. Aber auch so eine kleine Sozialkritik. Ich sehe häufig Leute mit Podcast-Ufo-Shirts. Aber die sehen mich nie. Vielleicht kennen auch viele mein Gesicht nicht, weil die meisten nur die Stimme kennen. Aber ich laufe so oft mit Leuten gegen die Podcast-Ufo-Shirt, die einfach so sehr in ihrem Handy stecken und gar nicht mehr die Umwelt wahrnehmen, dass ich gucke mal kurz davor, wenn du dir anzusprechen und sagen willst, willst du ein Foto machen? Und ich denke mir, das tut mir immer so leid, weil ich denke, das wäre vielleicht cool, aber naja, dann hört einfach bei der Musik und lauft durch die Stadt. Aber es ist schon interessant, dass man mittlerweile einfach so sehr eine kleine Sozialkritik aufs Handy klart. Ich habe im Zug zwei Reihen vor mir jemanden gesehen, der hat auf dem iPad deine Serie geschaut.
Ach, wirklich? einfach so sehr eine kleine Sozialkritik auf Handy start. Ich habe im Zug zwei Reihen vor mir jemanden gesehen, der hat auf dem iPad deine Serie
geschaut.
Ach, wirklich?
Und dann dachte ich mir so, ach ja, komm jetzt, den spreche ich an und sag so, hey,
ich kenne den, der das geschrieben hat.
Okay, alles klar.
Ja, leider viel Spaß.
Kein Spoiler.
Spoiler im Titel, pass auf, nicht den Titel lesen.
Hey, cool.
Ich setze mich wieder hin, okay, alles klar, kein Problem. Setze mich noch mal hin, alles klar. Steu ich oder so? Sorry, okay, nee, okay, gut. Ah, ja, cool, die kann ich nicht, aber egal. Cool, ja, kein Problem. Also auf jeden Fall vielen, vielen Dank, dass ihr da rumgekommen seid, mega cool. Vor allem cool, um auch Leipzig zu sehen, ich war noch nie in Leipzig, sehr schön. Ja, wir werden jetzt noch schön den Backstage-Raum besichtigen und ich bin gespannt. Und den Hauptbahnhof morgen früh und dann. Was Leipzig zu bieten? Tolle Stadt, ich war ja auch, ich persönlich war ja schon im Rundfunktanzorchester. Und tatsächlich muss man sehen, ja, komm. Schöner Bahnhof, tatsächlich. Ich habe Leipzig auf Platz zwei der drei schönsten Bahnhöfe Deutschlands gesetzt, weil schöner Bücherladen. Und was immer gut ist, wann ist ein Bücherladen gut? Wenn er Reklam-Bücher verkauft. So, dann weiss man immer, das ist ein guter Bücherladen und hier am Hauptbahnhof kann man immer Reklam-Bücher kaufen. Ganz fantastisch, ganz, ganz toll. Richtig gut. Toll, ja, Shoutout an Reklam. Reklam ist eine tolle, tolle Firma, tatsächlich. Und ich habe jetzt auch tatsächlich in meiner Stammbuchladen die Schmuddelecke entdeckt. Ich habe die Schmuddelecke für mich entdeckt. Ganz interessant, weil ich kaufe mir immer Brezen und stecke die aber nicht direkt ein. Sondern weil ich habe immer, ich habe grosse Panik, im Weg zu stehen. Ich will es nicht anderen Menschen im Weg zu stehen. Deswegen kaufefe ich die Brezeln, renne schnell weg, springe Leuten aus dem Weg und versuche, dann erst ein ruhiges Plätzchen zu finden, wo ich dann Rucksack ausziehen kann, Rucksack auf, Brezeln rein, Rucksack zu. So, und dann mache ich das in meinem Buchladen und suche mir da die stillste Ecke und habe jetzt erst bemerkt, dass ich Woche um Woche in die Schmuddelecke gehe, was ich gar nicht bemerkt habe, zu den ganzen Pornoheftchen, da meinen Rucksack auf dem Boot lege. Ich wusste nicht, wie Schmuddelecke ist. Schmuddelecke? Ach komm. Der Begriff war mir kein Begriff. Nee, klar, da gibt es die guten Heftchen, da gibt es die Oho, da gibt es die Schlüsselloch und mein Favorit, Porno-Heftchen, ganz normale Frauen. Jetzt tatsächlich. Ohne Scheiß, finde ich super attraktiv. Also wirklich, ganz normale Frauen. Was ich auch wirklich gut finde, was haben die davor probiert, was nicht funktioniert hat. Crazy, crazy as women. Einfach so wirklich stinknormal, komplett, wirklich überhaupt nicht, würde dir nicht auffallen auf der Strasse, ganz normale Frauen. Macht dir keine Sorgen. Also da gibt es eine grosse Auswahl, interessant, aber da verziehe ich mich jetzt immer und pack da Sachen in meinen Rucksack ein.
Aber da ist immer am wenigsten los, weil da irgendwie den Leuten ist es unangenehm oder so, oder die haben ein Abo oder so.
Aber dann sitzen aber auch immer die gleichen anderen, dein Onkel und so, sitzen dann auch und dann grüßt man sich morgens.
Naja, naja, es ist ja so die Frage, wer kauft das. Vor allem merkwürdig, jeder, der so ein Heftchen mal aufgemacht hat, merkt, dass die gar nicht wirklich nackt sind, sondern denen wurde, sag ich mal, der Intimbereich weggephotoshoppt. Die sehen aus, ist wirklich kein Witz, und jetzt alle lachen so, haha, weil ho, noch nie gehört.
Die sehen tatsächlich aus wie Barbies, denen wurde der Intimereich weggephotoshoppt. Ich habe in meinem Leben noch nicht gesehen. Ist wirklich so, und ich weiß nicht genau warum. Warum gibt es diese Sachen überhaupt? Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es irgendwie so Auflagen gibt, falls irgendwie, wenn man diese Magazine verkaufen will, dann muss man zur Verfügung stellen, dass bestimmte Sachen rausgeretuschiert werden. Aber als ich das erste Mal gesehen habe, ich dachte mir, bin ich bescheuert oder habe ich den weiblichen Körper komplett missverstanden? So sehen ganz normale Frauen aus? Ist denn da... Hast du dann mal ganz normale Frauen im Gessin geschaut? Das muss man erst freischalten. Aber ich stand da wirklich, wenn man mich beobachtet hat, minutenlang mit gerunzelter Stirn nah auf nah. Brezel essend davor und dachte so, denkt mir, was ist da los? Ganz merkwürdig, aber guckt wirklich mal in diese Hefte rein, es ist ein grotesker Anblick. Guckt mal in diese Hefte. Es ist so merkwürdig so, man kauft ja diese Hefte, um nackte Frauen zu sehen, und dann werden die zensiert und retuschiert, was ja total merkwürdig ist, weil ich denke mir, warum macht man das denn? Warum kauft man diese Hefte, um nackte Frauen zu sehen? Es gibt das Internet, aber... Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist so für, ich glaube so gerade im Trucker-Business ist das wichtig, so die auf der Autobahn kein Internet haben. Vielleicht geht das jetzt immer weiter zurück oder so. Idee, rechts, einfach im richtigen Abstand, Porno. So ein schöner Hardcore-Porn-kino. Aber der so, der muss aber eine private extra Lkw-Spur geben, von dem man die sieht. Und alle anderen dürfen die nicht befahren. Das ist eine gute Idee. 18 Jahre alt sein, um diese Spur zu befahren. Aber zum Thema Lkw-Fahrer ohne Internet. Ich hatte in meiner World of War... Du musst auch 18 Jahre alt sein, um überhaupt zu fahren. Das wusste ich. Als ich das erzählt habe, als Gag war das schon geplant. Vielleicht kann man es so machen, dass wenn man von unten schaut, sieht man findet Nemo und wenn man so aus Erwachsenenhöhe schaut Hardcore-Porno. Alle sind zufrieden, alle sind zufrieden. Aber zum Thema Lkw-Fahrer haben... Was macht Dori da? Das willst du nicht wissen, meine Damen. Hehehehe, der grosse Bruder tippt so den Fahrer an, keine Ahnung.
Zum Thema Lkw-Fahrer ohne Internet, tatsächlich hatte ich in meiner World of Warcraft-Gilde einen, der hat immer WoW gespielt, während er Lkw gefahren ist.
Da war da irgendwie so ein wichtiger Raid-Boss oder irgendwie so dunkler Tempel und er so, ja sorry, ich muss kurz rechts ranfahren jetzt für den Boss, alles klar, gib mir kurz eine Sekunde und wir so, bitte was, bitte was, wir haben Lady Wasch gemacht, während du komplett Auto gefahren bist, ja, aber krasser Typ, er ist einfach krasser Typ, aber gibt es auch, man weiß es nicht genau, die haben ein gutes Internet, lasst euch nicht verarschen, lasst euch nicht jeden Scheiss erzählen. Aber schaut das mal an, schickt mir ein paar Fotos, schickt mir ein paar gute. Die normalste Frau, die ihr findet, schickt mir ein Bild. Einfach so, wenn ihr sagt, also normaler geht's jetzt wirklich nicht mehr. Die normalsten Frauen. Maximal normal. Ja, wir müssen uns jetzt leider verabschieden, das war wirklich eine ganz tolle Tour, es hat wahnsinnig viel Spaß. Das war die Tour, letzte Show in Leipzig, letzte Tour. Aber wir können ja mal sagen, dass wir auch schon auch mal die Idee haben und Lust haben, noch ein bisschen mehr Deutschland zu bereisen und vielleicht mal noch mal was in der Richtung zu machen. Auf jeden Fall war das erstmal das grosse Finale, der gibt es auch später noch umsonst als Podcast-Tour 2018, 2019. Ja, das ist Ihr habt jetzt noch die Möglichkeit, uns an Mördstein zu besuchen, da kommen wir gleich.
Ansonsten haut rein, habt noch einen schönen Abend in der Welthauptstadt Leipzig, haut rein.
Ansonsten vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen Leipzig, ihr seid mit dabei und wir heben ab.
Macht's gut Leipzig, tschüss, tschau, tsch ciao, das war Furetin Will und Schaffertitze!